Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 31. Wir schreiten langsam voran auf die 100 zu, aber bis dahin ist noch ein bisschen. Ja, das Thema wird heute sich um was etwas Komplexeres drehen. Für die Leute, die einen seichtes Thema erwartet haben, euch muss ich leider enttäuschen. Es geht um Programmiersprachen und insbesondere um die Programmiersprache, zu Gast dazu Andreas Bogk und am Mikrofon wie gehabt Tim Pritlove. Ja, hier ist Chaosradio Express wieder zurück. Und jetzt kommt der unvermeidliche Mikrofontest. Hallo Andreas.
Hallo Tim.
Super. Wir können uns hören. Das ist schön. Ja, Andreas, für dich habe ich mal gebeten, hier ein etwas ausführlicheres Statement abzugeben zu einer Programmiersprache, die wir beide schon seit längerem im Auge haben. Die Programmiersprache heißt Dylan, sowie Bob Dylan zum Beispiel.
Oder Dylan Thomas.
Oder Dylan Thomas, D-Y-L-A-N. Und wir nehmen es gleich mal vorweg. Es ist eine Programmiersprache, die absoluten Exotenstatus hat, die sich nicht in weiter Verbreitung befindet, die nicht von tausenden Leuten von den Dächern gerufen wird, denen es keine 500 Seiten Bücher im Buchladen gibt. Und überhaupt niemand interessiert sich für Dylan. Aber wir sind beide der Meinung, dass das eigentlich ein sehr unangemessener Zustand ist. Und warum das so ist, das wollen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen erläutern. Ja, vielleicht kannst du mal ein bisschen was erst mal zu dir selber sagen. Du bist ja eigentlich auch schon seit Ewigkeiten am Hacken. Wann hast denn du losgelegt?
Das war so in den späten 80ern, als ich damals hieß er noch Pionierpalast, heute hieß er Fez, auf einem KC85 das Programmieren lernte. Und dann später im Haus der jungen Talente, dem heutigen ProDeville, auf eine Gruppe interessierter Menschen stieß, die nicht nur Software kopiert haben, weil anders ging das damals nicht, es gab ja noch gar kein Internet, sondern auch sich mit Rechnern beschäftigt haben und damit was man mit Rechnern tun kann. Kamen dann dort in diesem Haus der jungen Talente im Februar 90 auf dem Cocon mit dem Chaos Computer Club in Berührung. Das war so ein bisschen...
Der Cocon.
Ja, so ein bisschen East meets West und das ging dann mit der Fusion bei den Hackern relativ schnell.
Das stimmt.
Und ja, also ich mach das schon eine ganze Weile. Ich programmiere seit, naja, es müssen jetzt bald 20 Jahre sein.
Das heißt, du hast auch alle Untiefen gesehen.
Kann man so sagen, ja. Von Amateurprojekten bis hin zu Versagen auf industriellen Maßstab hab ich, glaube ich, alles schon mal in den Fingern gehabt.
Okay, aber das war dann nicht dein eigener Code?
Das war dann nicht mein eigener Code. Das war Code von anderen Leuten.
Ja, mit den Programmiersprachen ist das ja so eine Sache. Also ich hab auch eine Weile überlegt, als ich dieses Thema jetzt hier angehen wollte, wie kann man denn bitte in einem Podcast fast eine Programmiersprache erklären? Und ich denke, bevor wir das tun, sollte man vielleicht mal ein bisschen darauf eingehen, was eine Programmiersprache eigentlich ist, um einfach mal so klar zu machen, vor allem auch, wo das Problem liegt, weil ganz offensichtlich gibt es ein tiefer legendes Problem, denn es werden am laufenden Meter neue Programmiersprachen erfunden. Jedes Jahr gibt es immer wieder einen neuen Hype. Heute ist es Java, morgen ist es Ruby, übermorgen ist es, keiner weiß es so ganz genau. Und da gibt es natürlich auch einen Grund dafür, weil sich die Bedürfnisse immer wieder ändern und weil die Programmiersprachen in irgendeiner Form an die neuen Bedürfnisse angepasst werden müssen.
Ja, Programmiersprachen sind ein sehr interessantes Phänomen. Für den oberflächlichen Betrachter sieht es ein bisschen so aus, als hätte die Programmiersprache den Nutzen, dem Computer zu sagen, was er tun soll. So 10 Print Hallo, 20 Go to 10 und dann gibt er ganz oft Hallo aus. Das ist aber eigentlich nur die halbe Wahrheit, sondern eine Programmiersprache dient auch dazu, ein Problem für den Menschen greifbar zu machen, das im Computer gelöst wird, also Abstraktionsebenen aufeinander zu bauen mit Sprachmitteln. Wenn es nicht wäre, würden wir Computer mit 0 und 1 programmieren. Hat man früher getan, also so ein 50er-Jahre-Rechner, der hatte vor einem Panel, da waren ganz viele Schalter dran, die konnte man auf 0 oder 1 stellen und dann hat man da seinen Bootloader-Code in die Schalter reingetan und daneben so ein Lochband gehabt, wo dann der Rest des Codes drauf war, auch mit 0 und 1 ein Loch oder nicht Loch. Dann hat man das angeworfen, hat es berechnet, ging auch. Und viel mehr braucht der Computer eigentlich auch gar nicht. Also für den sind Programmiersprachen nicht gedacht, die dienen nicht dem Computer an sich, sondern die dienen dem Menschen dabei, ein Problem so zu strukturieren, dass es durch einen Computer lösbar wird.
Ganz allgemein unterscheidet man ja immer so zwischen der sogenannten Low-Level und der High-Level-Programmiersprache. Also eine Hochsprache ist ja so ein schön gestelltes Wort. Hast du denn das auch mit einer Hochsprache programmiert? Wo würdest du denn den Unterschied zwischen unten und oben ansetzen?
Ich denke, der Unterschied liegt in dem, was einem eine Programmiersprache an Abstraktionsebenen bereitstellt. Also das erste, was man ja hat, wenn man nicht mehr Nullen und Einsen programmieren will, ist ein Assembler, wo man dann nicht irgendwie den Hex-Code für eine Instruktion hinschreiben muss, sondern sagen kann, MOF Register 1, Komma Register 2, um Daten von Register 2 in Register 1 zu bewegen.
Das ist so die Granularität des Prozessors halt?
Genau, das ist, naja, das, was der Prozessor macht, ist eigentlich irgendwie das Hexbyte 7F. Das wird halt reingeladen und dekodiert und dann irgendwie eine Anweisung daraus gemacht. Und der Assembler ist eigentlich schon der erste Schritt Richtung Programmiersprache, der nämlich eine sogenannte Minimonic einführt für die Instruktion, also etwas, was der Mensch sich merken kann.
Ja, also sichererweise so eine 3-buchstabige oder 4-buchstabige Abkürzung für eine einfache Instruktion, die ein Prozessor ausführt.
Dem Computers ist es egal, ob da jetzt 7F steht oder MOF. Er muss sogar mehr arbeiten. Wenn man MOF hinschreibt, der muss nämlich erstmal 7F daraus machen. Das ist durchaus aufwendig. Und da kommen in verschiedenen Sprachen Schritt für Schritt weitere Abstraktionsebenen dazu, die einem helfen, etwas problemnäher und Hardware ferner auszudrücken. Der nächste Schritt sind dann Sprachen, die halt nicht prozessorspezifisch sind. Das heißt, irgendwie ein MOF-Befehl funktioniert auf dem einen Rechner so, auf dem anderen funktioniert er anders, die Register sehen anders aus, die Speicheradressierung und so weiter und so fort.
Genau, was auch der Grund ist, warum halt ein Macintosh mit einem PowerPC Prozessor einen anderen Code braucht als ein Macintosh mit einem Intel-Prozessor.
Genau, und da man sich nicht hinsetzen möchte und alles zweimal programmieren, ist die nächste Abstraktionsebene, die das Leben einfacher macht, dann halt eine Sprache, die etwas weiter oben funktioniert, die dann auf allen Architekturen gleich aussieht und die nach unten hin in verschiedene Assembler-Befehle umgesetzt wird. Und das ist so ein bisschen kontinuum. Das geht dann in den Abstraktionsebenen weiter nach oben. Wenn man dann anfängt, eine leichtere Konstruktion zu haben. Einfache Sprachen haben dann, keine Ahnung, eine Vorschleife und ein If und kennen Integer und Floating Point und String und Structs. Und was ja auch schon Abstraktionen sind. Also in Assembler gibt es keine Structs.
Also C-Programmierer sollten sich jetzt heimisch gefühlt haben bei denen.
Genau, C ist im Prinzip ein High-Level Assembler. Ein Assembler, der einen schon mal von der Architektur ein wenig unabhängiger macht. Also es ist nicht ganz, es ist nicht ganz weg. Man merkt das immer noch so ein bisschen durch, was da vielleicht die Kultur drunter ist.
Ja, das ist aber echt eine moderne Sicht. Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, als es so mit C anfing, da galt das ja im Prinzip schon als die Hochsprache. Also da war ja im Prinzip der Gedanke, überhaupt nicht mehr Assembler zu programmieren, also eine Programmiersprache zu nehmen, die Prozesse unabhängig ist, galt da ja schon als was ganz fortgeschritten. Also auch wenn das natürlich andere Programmiererkulturen schon lange getan haben. Ja, das war in dem Sinne nichts Neues. Trotzdem wurde C schon so ein bisschen auch als extrem advanced angesehen, was es aber eigentlich nicht ist. Weil es ja eigentlich nur eine Abstraktion des Prozessors ist.
Es war schon ein Fortschritt. Also es gibt von Butler Lampson, dem damaligen Chef von Xerox, der so Sachen wie Laserdrucker und den PC und die Maus und das Ethernet erfunden hat, die Aussage, es gibt kein Problem, was man durch den Zufügen eine zusätzlichen Abstraktionsebene lösen kann. Und C hat ja schon Probleme gelöst damals. Man konnte halt irgendwie schneller programmieren als vorher, als man alles in Assembler programmiert hat.
Dann zu Betriebssystemen.
Ja, obwohl Unix, also allein der Name sagt es ja schon, Unix war als, der Name war als Witz gemeint im Verhältnis zu Multics, was damals ein Großrechnerbetriebssystem war, das auch relativ verbreitet war, das in einer Programmiersprache namens PL1 geschrieben war. Und da reden wir von den 60ern. Also es gab auch vorher schon richtige Programmiersprachen, in denen Betriebssysteme geschrieben wurden, aber halt nicht bei der Masse da draußen. Also die ganzen Leute, die sich mit Minicomputern, Homecomputern in den 70ern beschäftigt haben, die hatten zu sowas keinen Zugang, weil es das einfach nicht gab.
Wenn man jetzt ein bisschen in die Geschichte taucht, dann gibt es da einen Namen, der immer wieder auftaucht, als so ein bisschen die Mutter aller Programmiersprachen. Das ist die Programmiersprache LISP, die in der Programmierer-Community eigentlich nur zwei Arten von Anhängern hat. Also entweder fanatische Befürworter oder fanatische Ablehner dieses Ansatzes. Aber LISP spielt schon eine ganz spezielle Rolle, weil es erstens eine der allerersten Sprachen war und sie auch bis heute, will ich sagen, unerreicht ist, aber sie hat zumindest so viele grundlegende Konzepte von Anfang an realisiert. Sodass viele Programmiersprachen, die später entstanden sind, dann immer wieder ab irgendeinem Weiterentwicklungszyklus dann beschlossen hat, naja, okay, das eine, was wir weggelassen haben, was LISP schon hatte, das müssen wir jetzt dann doch mal wieder einbauen. Was ist denn die besondere Stellung von LISP?
Da muss man vielleicht ein bisschen ausholen, und zwar zu den Grundlagen der Informatik und der Rechner, die wir heute haben. Also vielen ist ja die Turing-Maschine geläufig. Nicht mehr ganz so vielen Menschen ist geläufig, was der Turing-Maschine ist. Die Turing-Maschine ist ein theoretisches Konstrukt, das sich Alan Turing mal ausgedacht hat, um einen Beweis zu führen. Und da ging es um das sogenannte Halteproblem. Das ist ganz grob gesprochen die Frage, ob man entscheiden kann, ob ein bestimmtes Programm irgendwann stehen bleibt und ein Ergebnis produziert oder ob es immer weiterläuft und sich in einer Endschluss-Schleife verfängt. Das hat bewiesen, dass man nicht beweisen kann, dass ein Programm immer das Ergebnis liefert. Und um den Beweis zu führen, braucht er natürlich eine mathematische Konstruktion, um diesen Sachverhalt abzubilden. Und hat sich halt, wie das bei Mathematikern so ist, auf die sogenannte Piano-Arithmetik beschränkt. Also das Plus-Minus-Mal-Durch ist das quasi und Zahlen. Und hat sich die Turing-Maschine definiert. Die definiert sich im Prinzip aus einem endlosen Band, auf dem Symbole stehen, und einer Zustandstabelle und einem Zustand, den diese Turing-Maschine hat. Es gibt also einen initialen Zustand. Und dann macht das Ding einfach die ganze Zeit. Lese das Symbol vom Band, gucke in der Tabelle nach, was für den Zustand, in dem ich mich gerade befinde und das Symbol, das ich gelesen habe, der nächste Zustand ist. Und springe den an. Und kann dann irgendwie nach links und rechts fahren und so weiter und so fort. Und man kann halt zeigen, dass Programme, die man damit schreibt, equivalent sind zu allen sogenannten berechenbaren Problemen. Also es gibt da eine Definition von Rekursiv berechenbar und es gibt die Turing-Maschinen. Letzten Endes ist es alles äquivalent zueinander. War damals relativ einschlagend, weil diese Turing-Maschine schon relativ nah an dem dran war, wie heutige Computer funktionieren. Das heißt, man konnte dieses mathematische Konstrukt Turing-Maschine nehmen, konnte etwas bauen, was sehr, sehr ähnlich ist. Nämlich ein Computer, der hat halt kein endloses Band, sondern hat einen endlichen Speicher. Aber im Prinzip liest er auch ein Symbol vom Band, also eine Instruktion, eine Rechnerinstruktion aus dem Speicher. Und abhängig von dem, was er gelesen hat und dem, was sein Zustand ist, führt er dann das nächste aus. Also man kann das so ein bisschen darauf abbilden, man kann sich das sehr anschaulich vorstellen. Man kann es als Maschine bauen. Das ist so das, was dieses Modell sexy macht. Dann kam aber ein halbes Jahr später ein gewisser Alonzo Church. Und der hat denselben Beweis nochmal geführt, den Thuring auch geführt hat. Und wo Thuring halt irgendwie ein doch eher stattliches Büchlein abgeliefert hat, hat Church halt mit Hilfe des sogenannten Lambda-Kalküls es geschafft, den Beweis in wenigen Seiten zu führen. Also das Lambda-Kalkül...
Das klingt nach einem sehr komplizierten Begriff.
Das klingt nach einem sehr komplizierten Begriff. Die Theorie dazu ist teilweise auch sehr kompliziert, aber was das Lambda-Kalkül eigentlich ist, ist schnell erklärt. Wenn man sich mal an seine Schulzeit zurückerinnert, dann hat man manchmal so Sachen geschrieben, kam es irgendwann Funktionen, dann hat man geschrieben, f von x ist gleich x². Und man hat dann irgendwann als Schüler mal gelernt, wenn man dann die Funktion f für den Wert 3 berechnen will, dann muss man halt irgendwie für x eine 3 einsetzen auf der einen Seite. Also schreibt man f von 3 und dann muss man halt die x auf der anderen Seite auch durch ein 3 ersetzen. Und das Lambda-Kalkül ist nichts anderes als diese Ersetzung. That's it, das ist alles. Und das reicht halt aus, um sich die ganze Welt zu bauen. Man kann dann mit Hilfe des Lambda-Kalküls sowas wie If-Ausdrücke bauen, man kann die Zahlen von 0 bis n bauen, indem man sich eine Null definiert und eine Nachfolgerfunktion. Das Ganze funktioniert dadurch, dass man für x auch wieder Funktionen einsetzen kann. Also man kann sozusagen, wenn man f von x hat, kann man f auf f zu hinschreiben und dann hat man zwar f zum Quadrat, was irgendwie erstmal sinnlos ist. Und man kann sich andere Konstruktionen bauen, indem das dann wieder Sinn ergibt.
Also anstatt dass ich eine Zahl einsetze, setze ich eine Funktion ein, die dann wiederum genauso wie die normale Funktion erstmal irgendwas aufruft, was tut. Und das, was diese zweite Funktion zurückliefert, ist dann das, was in die erste Funktion eingesetzt wird.
Na, die Funktion selber wird eingesetzt in die Funktion.
Aha, okay, verstehe. Also nicht das Ergebnis, sondern die Funktion als Element, was weitergereicht wird.
Diese ganze Turing-Maschine und die Denkweise, die dahinter steckt, hat dann auch zu den, ich sag jetzt mal, klassischen Programmiersprachen geführt. Also sowas wie Fortran war dann eine der ersten Sprachen, die implementiert wurden, Kobol, die diese Idee, irgendwie tue das, dann tue das, dann tue das, versucht haben, ein bisschen auf einen höheren Level zu ziehen. Parallel dazu ist am MIT ein Mathematiker auf die Idee gekommen, man könnte doch auch aus dem Lambda-Kalkül eine Programmiersprache bauen. Also es war nicht ganz die Herangehensweise, das war so ein bisschen eine Fusion aus, wir spielen jetzt mal mit dem Rechner rum und wir versuchen da mal was zu bauen, was uns Antworten liefert und halt den theoretischen Konstrukt im Hintergrund. Der Zweck, für den LISP damals entwickelt wurde, war, dass die Erfinder damit ein Programm schreiben wollten, das symbolisch integrieren und differenzieren kann, also eine Funktion ableiten wollte man automatisieren. Ist auch alles in den 50ern passiert, also so 54, 55 rum ist die Geburtstunde von LISP gewesen, 58 dann die erste Reimplementierung auf einer PDPA1.
Damals waren halt auch Programmierer alles so Mathe-Freaks eigentlich, oder?
Ja, teilweise, aber es gab halt auch immer den ingenieurstechnischen Aspekt. Also gerade die frühen Computer waren ja einer Modelleisenbahnanlage nicht unbedingt unähnlich, sodass also die MIT-Hacker-Kultur aus dem Techmodel Railroad Club hervorgegangen ist, wo sie halt schon vorher mit Relais und Weichen und so weiter und automatisierten Systemen rumgespielt haben, was auch sehr, sehr nah war. Also das war so ein bisschen das Zusammentreffen von Ingenieuren, Hardware-Freakern auf der einen Seite und Mathematikern auf der anderen Seite.
Okay, aber warum dann LISP? Was wollten sie machen?
Na, sie wollten symbolisch integrieren erstmal und haben unterwegs festgestellt, dass es eine sehr nützliche Sprache ist, eigentlich um alle Probleme zu lösen.
Also mit symbolisch integrieren meinst du, sie wollten Formeln auflösen?
So was wie ableiten, so leite mir mal x² ab und dann soll die das Ding sagen, irgendwie als 2x. So was wie Mathematiker heute. Haben sie übrigens auch geschafft? Also es gab dann irgendwie zehn Jahre später MaxSyma. MaxSyma war die erste wichtige LISP-Anwendung, die halt Symbolic Mathematics machen konnte, also MaxSyma, da der Name. Im Laufe der Zeit sind viele Konzepte aus anderen Sprachen dazugekommen, aber LISP hatte auch einige originäre Konzepte, zum Beispiel das mit der Garbage Collection war etwas, was von Anfang an in LISP eingebaut war.
Garbage Collection ist, wenn man sich nicht selber in seinem Programm darum kümmern muss, dass der Computer Speicher bereitstellt und dass man es auch wieder frei geben muss, sondern dass das alles automatisiert abläuft, indem der Müllmann vorbeikommt und die Objekte einfach einsammelt, die man eh nicht mehr braucht.
Automatisiert Speicherverwaltung. Genau. LISP hat im Laufe der Zeit dann, also angefangen hat es auf jeden Fall mit, auch mit dynamischer Typisierung, das heißt ein Objekt selber wusste zur Laufzeit, ob es jetzt ein Integer ist oder ein Float oder ein Character oder ein was auch immer. Also es gab eigentlich kein objektorientiertes System, so wie wir das heute kennen damals. Es gab so eine Reihe von fundamentalen Typen, die aber dynamisch waren. Also ähnlich wie man das heute von sogenannten Skript-Sprachen kennt, also wenn man mal Perl oder Python oder PHP oder sowas programmiert hat, da muss man den Typ einer Variable nicht deklarieren, sondern man weiß der Variablen was zu und das Objekt, das dann in der Variable drin steckt, hat einen Typ.
Das ist aber auch wirklich täglich Brot beim Programmieren. Variablen, das kommt halt in jeder Zeile vor. Man muss permanent Werte von A nach B schaufeln, umrechnen, an Funktionen übergeben, Rückgabewerte auswerten. Ich versuche nur gerade nochmal klar zu machen, was man sich unter dynamisch an der Stelle vorstellen muss. Da gibt es ganz offensichtlich sehr unterschiedliche Auffassungen darüber, was dynamisch nun tatsächlich ist. Aber du bezeichnest jetzt dynamisch in dem Kontext primär als das Objekt, weil es einfach mal über sich selbst Bescheid.
Genau, dynamische Typisierung ist das im Grunde genommen. Es gibt noch mehr dynamische Aspekte an LISP. Eins davon ist, dass der Compiler zur Laufzeit ständig verfügbar ist. Das heißt, man hat bei LISP nicht den üblichen Edit-Compile-Run-Cycle, wenn man entwickelt, sondern man entwickelt eigentlich am lebenden Programm. Also das Programm, das man entwickelt, und die Entwicklungsumgebung, mit der man das entwickelt, die bilden eine große Einheit. Und man programmiert sehr viel dadurch, dass man halt mal eine Zeile Code eintippt und Return drückt und guckt, was passiert. Und wenn es funktioniert hat, dann tut man das ins Source-File rüber und schreibt dann weiter. Also eigentlich von Anfang an, von der ersten Zeile, lebender Code. So, im Gegensatz zu dem Modell, ja, wir machen hier einen großen Plan und dann machen wir ganz viele Module. Und dann implementieren ganz viele Programmierer die ganz vielen Module und dann stecken wir das zusammen und wundern uns, dass es nicht funktioniert. Was sicherlich sehr zum Erfolg von LISP beigetragen hat, ist, dass die Struktur der Sprache selber, dadurch, dass sie sehr, sehr simpel ist, sich auch leicht automatisiert verarbeiten lässt. Das heißt, in LISP war man schnell dabei, sogenannte Metaprogrammierungen zu machen. Das heißt, Programme zu schreiben, die Programme bearbeitet haben, die Programme generiert haben oder über das Hausgrut drüber gelaufen sind, die ihn geändert haben. Wenn man sich LISP anguckt, das erste Feature, das einem auffällt, sind, dass es da ganz unheimlich viele Klammern gibt und dass es irgendwie so ein bisschen grauenhaft aussieht.
Das hat auch ganz maßgeblich zur Unpopularität von LISP beigetragen.
Ich denke, das ist ein Grund, ja. Aber die LISP-Proponenten sagen, und nicht ganz zu unrecht, dass viel der Macht von LISP aus dieser Syntax herkommt. Ich denke, dass wir heutzutage so weit sind, dass wir dasselbe erreichen können und trotzdem eine etwas reichere, etwas komplexere Syntax verwenden können. Dylan tut das bereits zu einem gewissen Teil. Und wenn wir sicherlich über Makros reden, werden wir noch ein bisschen drauf eingehen. Aber so die Essenz von LISP ist eigentlich die sogenannte Rappel, die Read, Eval, Print, Loop.
Noch mal langsam bitte.
Rappel, R-E-P-L, Read, Eval, Print, Loop. Und das sind die Namen der vier Funktionen, die man aufrufen muss, um sich so einen LISP-Interpreter in LISP zu schreiben. Man sagt nämlich Read. Read liest Zeichen von der Command Line und interpretiert das als Programm und gibt einem einen Syntax-Trieb zurück. Also im Prinzip eine sehr einfache Abbildung bei LISP. Man schreibt halt Klammer auf, Foo, Bar, Bats, Klammer zu. Der macht da draußen eine Liste, in der die Symbole Foo, Bar und Bats drin sind. Wenn man halt Klammer auf Foo, Klammer auf Bar hat, dann hat man halt eine Liste, wo eine Liste drin ist, und so weiter und so fort. Also es ist sehr, sehr einfach, diese Klammer-Syntax auf eine Struktur von verschachtelten Listen abzubilden. Das macht Read. EWAL nimmt dann solche Listen von Listen, interpretiert sie als LISP-Programm. Print gibt dann den Wert aus und Loop muss man auch drum rumschreiben, dass man wieder einen neuen Prompt kriegt. Jetzt kann man natürlich an jedem Schritt davon rumarbeiten. Das heißt, man kann irgendwie zwischen Read und EWAL losgehen und über seine Listen von Listen drüber laufen und Ersetzungen durchführen, Umstellungen durchführen, und so weiter und so fort. Das hat LISP so ein bisschen zum Labor für Sprachforscher gemacht, also für Programmiersprachenforscher. Es war halt traditionell die Sprache, wo es am einfachsten war, wenn man eine Idee hatte für ein neues Sprachfeature, das mal eben einzubauen. Und deswegen hat LISP im Laufe der Zeit eigentlich alles, was an neuen Sprachfeatures kam, was populär wurde, was sich als sinnvollen, erfolgreich herausgestellt hat, aufgesungen, integriert und assimiliert. Und hat sich deswegen lange entwickelt.
Ohne dass die Sprache sich dabei auch selbst groß verbiegen muss.
Ja, also man sieht dem Common-LISP-Standard schon so ein bisschen an, dass er gewachsen ist. Also man muss da nicht viel dran verbiegen, aber durch die historisch gewachsene Struktur sind halt so viele Dinge dabei, die könnten schöner sein. Da gibt es zum Beispiel, also üblicherweise in LISP werden Listen aus sogenannten Cons-Sales generiert. Also Paare, die in Head und in Tail haben, zwei Werte, und dann tut man in Head halt den Wert, den man speichern will, in Tail tut man den Rest der Liste, bis man halt in Tail mal die leere Liste tut, damit es fertig ist. Und um auf das erste Element und das zweite Element von so einem Paar zuzugreifen, gibt es die Funktion K und CDR. Das steht für Contents of Address Register und Contents of Decrement Register. Was die entsprechenden Assemblerbefehle waren auf der ersten CPU, irgendeine IBM-Maschine, auf der sie das implementiert hatten. Und Common Lisp ist halt so ein bisschen angegraut. Und das ist eigentlich auch schon der Punkt, wo Dylan ins Spiel kommt, weil Dylan eigentlich hervorgegangen ist, aus dem Versuch der Common Lisp-Leute mal ein modernes, aufgeräumtes Lisp zu machen. Also die ganzen Features, die sie im Laufe der Zeit eingesammelt haben, wie das mit der Objektorientierung und ähnliches, die Art und Weise, wie Typsysteme funktionieren, auch ein bisschen darauf eingehen, wie die Compiler-Technologie sich entwickelt hat. Also was kann man schnell und performant kompilen und was nicht, mal zu nehmen, ordentlich aufzuräumen, den Sachen mal ordentlich in Namen zu geben. Und das Resultat davon ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger Dylan. Also auch die Leute, die am Dylan-Standard beteiligt waren, waren Leute, die vorher den Common-LISP-Standard gemacht haben, die vorher in LISP-Compilern gearbeitet haben.
Aber nicht alle. Das war sozusagen nur so ein kleines, gallisches Dorf oder kann man schon davon sagen, dass die LISP-Community generell dem Dylan-Projekt positiv gegenüber stand?
Es gab eine Zeit, wo die LISP-Community Dylan sehr wohlwollend gesehen hat. Das war ungefähr bis irgendjemand beschlossen hat, dass Dylan eine moderne Syntax kriegt, also das mit den Klammern mal weggelassen wird. Und an der Stelle sind halt die Oldschool-LISPer alle abgesprungen, weil sie gesagt haben, das ist dann nicht mehr schön elegant und einfach. Also ich kann mittlerweile die Features benennen, die im derzeitigen Dylan-Standard noch nicht drin sind, die damals diese Leute zu der Meinung veranlasst haben. Ich bin aber der Meinung, dass man das in Dylan durchaus nachrüsten kann. Also es ist echt nicht viel, was man tun muss, um die selbe Mächtigkeit zu haben, wie existierende Common-LISP-Implementierungen. gemacht wurde das, also Dylan hat eine Syntax, die nicht nach Klammern aussieht, sondern die so, wie diese Algo-Familien von Sprachen, Pascal Modula mit Beginn und End, die ja sehr bekannt sind. Die sehr bekannt sind, also, naja, ich weiß nicht, Syntax ist auch nicht skin-deep, mittlerweile muss ich sagen, mir wär's eigentlich egal, ob das jetzt irgendwie die Klammer-Syntax oder die andere Syntax ist, die andere ist meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen besser lesbar, weil so was wie Zuweisungen besser herausstechen, weil man nicht bloß eine Klammer zu hat, sondern...
Man kann halt schreiben A gleich 5. Wie seh das in LISP aus?
Würde man sagen im ZF5A. Und dieses Doppelpunkt gleich ist schon im Southcote wesentlich prägnanter. Auch Gleichungen finde ich in der Infix-Syntax besser lesbar.
Also Infix-Syntax muss man dazu sagen, das ist die Bezeichnung dafür.
Genau.
Und was ist die Bezeichnung für die LISP-Syntax?
Das ist Präfix. Man immer schreibt Klammer auf plus 1, 2 Klammer zu. Und also die Funktion, die aufgerufen wird, im Präfix steht.
So ein bisschen auch wie diese Taschenrechner mit ihrer umgekehrt polnischen Notation.
Ja, es ist sozusagen umgekehrt, umgekehrt polnische Notation, also polnische Notation für Mathematiker.
Okay, das heißt an der Stelle beginnt im Prinzip die Geschichte von Dylan. Wir befinden uns jetzt im Jahre, gute Frage, wann war denn das? Mitte der 90er Jahre?
Na, schon späten 80er, frühen 90ern. Also frühen 90er ist das Dylan Interim Referenzmanual rausgekommen, noch mit der Präfix-Syntax. Ein bisschen später dann das Dylan Referenzmanual, das muss so 94 gewesen sein und dann 95, die erste Implementierung von Apple, die veröffentlicht wurde. Zurück geht das Ganze auf den Versuch, doch ein alternatives Betriebssystem für den Apple Newton zu implementieren. Da gab es damals den Ansatz, eine Sprache namens RAV zu schreiben.
Also der Newton, der erste Rechner, der eigentlich PDA hieß. Apple hat ja damals diesen Begriff mit dem Newton geboren, so der Personal Digital Assistant. Später wurde nur über den Palm Pilot der Begriff noch weiter bekannt.
Ja, sie waren da glaube ich 10 Jahre zu früh mit diesem Produkt.
Das glaube ich allerdings auch. Sehr ambitioniert, also immerhin. Also ich meine, so vom User-Interface ist eigentlich das, was man sich wünscht, aber die Maschine hat halt einfach zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht die notwendigen Parameter geboten. Das betrifft ja im Prinzip auch die Programmiersprache, weil man hat dann schnell festgestellt, dass Dylan da einfach viel zu hohe Anforderungen hat.
Ja, es war die absolut hohe Forderung nach einem Megabyte Flash für die Sprachrantanen, was halt damals absolut utopisch war, weil das Gerät insgesamt nicht mehr hatte. Und zu Tage hat jeder ein Mobiltelefon mit 64 Megabyte Flash in der Tasche. Wenn nicht gar irgendwie eine SD-Karte mit einem Gigabyte drinsteckt für die Fotos.
Oder ein iPod Nano mit 4 Gigabyte.
Das ist also eine Beschränkung, dass die heute nicht mehr da war. Aber damals war sie halt da. Deswegen wurde das Projekt fallen gelassen. Man hat sich damals dann darauf konzentriert, eine Implementierung für den Desktop zu machen. Also es gab die Vorstellung, ein Entwicklungssystem zu bauen für den Desktop mit IDE und viel Komfort und allem drum und dran. Das waren damals die Apple Cambridge Laboratories, die Leute, die auch Macintosh Common Lisp implementiert haben. Es gab drei weitere Gruppen. Also es gab insgesamt drei Gruppen, die an Dylan gearbeitet haben. Im Prinzip alles alte Lisp-Leute. Die Apple Cambridge Laboratories waren das dann eine Gruppe an der Carnegie Mellon Universität, die damals CMU Common Lisp geschrieben hat, die danach an dem Gwydion-Projekt gearbeitet hat. Und die dritte war eine Firma namens Harlequin, die hervorgegangen ist aus, also viele der Leute, es hat mit der Firma nichts zu tun, aber viele der Leute, die vorher bei Symbolics waren, ein Hersteller von Lisp-Maschinen, also speziellen Computern, deren Betriebssystem in Lisp geschrieben war.
Genau, komplette Maschine, ausschließlich in Lisp von vorne bis hinten.
Das waren in den 80ern die coolen Hacker-Computer, mit denen man gearbeitet hat, wenn man 3D-Grafik gemacht hat oder künstliche Intelligenz oder nach Öl gebohrt usw. Die sind pleite gegangen wegen eines schiefgegangenen Immobilien-Spekulationsprojektes des Eigentümers, was sehr bedauerlich ist. Jedenfalls sind die Leute bei Harlequin gelandet, haben da den Lisp-Works-Compiler geschrieben, also auch Lisp-Leute, und dann an Harlequin-Düllen gearbeitet. Aus dem Apple-Projekt ist nicht so viel geworden. Es gab eine Technology-Release, die wirklich für damalige Verhältnisse atemberaubend war. Wenn man davor mit VIE-C-Code programmiert hat und dann diese IDE gesehen hat, dann wollte man einfach nicht mehr zurück, weil die damals schon mehr konnte als Eclipse heute. Das heißt, Navigation zwischen Source-Code durch einfach auf einen Bezeichner draufklicken, automatisches Malen von Call-Grafen und von Klassengrafen mit Einklappen und Ausklappen, Object-Browsern, Interaktion mit den Programmen, d.h. man konnte sein Programm anhalten, mal kurz eine Funktion ändern und wieder laufen lassen, mal kurz einen Düllenausdruck eingeben, in sein Programm schicken, da evaluieren usw. Also die ganzen tollen, schicken Features, die man heutzutage auch haben will, die Java mit Eclipse jetzt schrittchenweise auch bekommt, die waren da alle da.
Vor allem für damalige Verhältnisse auf McIntosh absolut berauscht, das Programm ist nie abgestürzt. Und das, obwohl es in so einem totalen Alpha-Zustand war, wenn mal irgendwas intern vollkommen im Eimer war, dann war es jederzeit immer noch in der Lage, einem Fenster anzuzeigen, zu sagen, ich bin jetzt konfus und komm nicht mehr klar, aber ich speicher jetzt nochmal dein Projekt ab, bevor ich mich beende.
Es ist ja heute bei Computern auch nicht anders, dass die Anwendungen nicht doch gelegentlich mal crashen und die Daten mitnehmen. Das war schon ein sehr bemerkenswerter Unterschied, dass, obwohl diese Software noch nicht fertig war, Fehler in der Software Bugs nicht dazu geführt haben, dass alles gecrashed ist, sondern das System kontrolliert den Fehler, empfangen und bearbeitet und gehandelt hat, dann ein Menü angezeigt hat, so, lieber User, ich weiß jetzt nicht weiter, willst du es nochmal probieren? Willst du abbrechen? Willst du in Debugger gehen?
Oder ein Bugreport ausdrucken.
So was. Sehr beeindruckend. Leider ging es Apple dann finanziell sehr, sehr schlecht in dem Jahr. Und sie mussten ihre Forschung auf die Hälfte zusammenstreichen. Und die gesamten Ausgaben auf die Hälfte.
Das war richtig brutal. Apple hat halt so ins Klo gefasst mit seiner Systemssoftware-Entwicklung und mit der Transition auf den Power-PC. Die haben ja dann auch ihren Chef rausgeschmissen. Mr. Michael Spindler hat es halt völlig vergeigt. Und danach begann halt diese große Krise, wo dann eben Microsoft auch schaffte, mit Windows 95 dann in der Öffentlichkeit komplett an Apple vorbeizuziehen. Der ganze Nimbus der Führungsnation war dann komplett dahin. Und leider mussten eben auch diese ganzen Entwicklungsprojekte dran glauben. Aber das hieß ja nicht, dass an Dylan nicht mehr weitergearbeitet wurde, weil es gab ja noch Harlequin, die wir schon erwähnt haben, und die Carnegie Mellon University, wo es ja auch ein wichtiges Projekt gab.
Fangen wir mal mit der CMU an. Interessanterweise der Projektleiter an der CMU des Gwydian-Projektes und auch des CMU Communist Compiler-Projektes davor war Scott Fahlmann, der den meisten Leuten kein Begriff ist, obwohl er eigentlich als Erfinder des SMILEY, also ihr wisst schon, Doppelpunkt minus, Klammer zu, der hat sich das damals ausgedacht, ein Begriff sein sollte. Also auch jemand, der irgendwie schon eine Weile dabei ist. Die hatten auch die Vorstellung, so was ähnliches zu schreiben wie Apple mit der Apple-Dylan-IDI, also so eine Entwicklungsumgebung, wo man Code-Browsern konnte und so weiter und so fort. Das war ein Konzept, das Smalltalk eigentlich mal aufgebracht hat. Also Smalltalk hatte das mit den Class-Browsern schon vor allen anderen. Und die sowas auch machen wollten und dafür erstmal in C einen Dylan-Interpreter geschrieben haben, der wie Interpreter, das so an sich haben, nicht besonders performant war, dafür schnell fertig.
Das finde ich aber schon einen ziemlich harten Task, also so eine kompletten, hohe Sprache wie Dylan und so viele Features und Ausdrucksreichtum dann erstmal in C zu realisieren als erstes.
Ja, es geht. Sie haben es sich einfach gemacht dadurch, dass sie sich quasi einen sehr begrenzten Subset von Dylan definiert haben, der im Prinzip genau Klassen unterstützt und Funktionen und sich viel von der eigentlichen Logik dann in Dylan selber geschrieben haben. Also vieles von der Basis-Library. Und dann im nächsten Schritt in Dylan einen Dylan-Compiler geschrieben haben. Also einen Interpreter in C zu schreiben war noch zumutbar und einen Compiler in C zu schreiben wollte sich dann doch keiner mehr antun.
Und den Namen solltest du erwähnen, den finde ich nämlich lustig. Mindy. Heißt Mindy is not Dylan yet.
Naja, und mit Hilfe dieses Interpreters konnte der Compiler dann erst mal interpretiert werden, um sich selber zu compilen. Und dann gab es halt einen Compiler, der compilert war und dann auch hinreichend viel schneller war. Der Compiler...
So löst man das Henne-Ei-Problem sozusagen.
Genau, so löst man das Henne-Ei-Problem bei Programmiersprachen. Das ist halt immer so. Also auch GCC muss man mit GCC compilen und der wurde bestimmt mal mit einem anderen C-Compiler gebootstrapped, den sich Richard Stormen irgendwo ausgeborgt hat.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass er ihn empfangen hat.
Meinst du, er hat einen C-Interpreter in PDP 7 Assembler geschrieben?
Ich glaube einfach nur, dass er sich irgendwie hingestellt hat mit seinem heiligen Schein und er hatte einfach die notwendige Software zum Start.
Oh, die Compiler. Genau, kommt zu mir. Aber der Compiler, der an der CMU geschrieben wird, T2C, wie der Name schon sagt, übersetzt Dylan in C. Was er zum Beispiel auch die erste C++-Implementierung C-Front gemacht hat. Das hat Vorteile und Nachteile, erstmal nach C zu compilen, um dann weiter auf Assembler runter zu compilen. Der Nachteil ist der, dass man keine ganz so gute Kontrolle darüber hat, was jetzt wirklich unten bei den Bits passiert, weil man immer noch davon abhängig ist, die Stack-Frames von C und die Calling-Convention von C mit zu benutzen, um da Dinge zu tun. Und so ein paar Randprobleme, wie dass man dann hinterher im Speicher nicht mehr weiß, was ein Pointer und ein Integer ist und deswegen bestimmte Dinge anders strukturieren muss. Es hat aber den großen Vorteil für den Compiler-Author, dass er sich nicht darum kümmern muss, für alle Architekturen Backends zu schreiben und da die Optimierung für zu schreiben. Und was man halt bei einem modernen RISC-Compiler tun muss, so Pipeline-Strukturen kennen, um dann Instruction-Reordering zu machen, was sehr, sehr aufwendig ist. Und in GCC werden so was wie 10 Millionen pro Jahr tatsächlich von Firmen investiert, um Portierungen auf Architekturen zu machen. Und also D2C ist eigentlich dadurch sehr, sehr schnell. Also das, was man auf High-Level an Optimierung machen kann auf Düllenebene, das macht er halt, erzeugt nach unten C-Code. Und der C-Code wird dann halt vom GCC oder was man auch immer für einen C-Compiler unten dranhängt, nochmal weiter optimiert auf Maschinenebene runter.
Und da kommt dann auch schon brauchbar Performanter Code bei raus?
Da kommt brauchbar Performanter Code bei raus. Also wir könnten schon sagen, dass mit der statischen, dynamischen Typisierung Type-Inheritance vielleicht nochmal auf später verschieben. Auf jeden Fall ist es so, dass da eine ganze Menge gemacht wird und wir also schon in Benchmarks so bis auf 10% an die Performance von der tiefgeschriebenen C-Code rankommen.
So, das heißt, um es nochmal zusammenzufassen, müssen wir nochmal auf die Sprache als solches kommen, aber die Geschichte lief im Kern so, bei Apple wurde die ganze Entwicklung mal wirklich seriös gestartet, aber dann wegen der Firmeninterner Verpeilung beendet. CMU hat weiter daran gearbeitet und Harlequin, diese LISP-Bude hat auch daran gearbeitet. Die haben ja einen richtigen LISP, einen richtigen Dylan-Compiler auch in Dylan gemacht, der richtig Assembler produziert hat, also ein vollwertiges System, auch mit einer IDE, also mit einem User-Interface für eine komplette Entwicklungsumgebung. Nur war das Problem natürlich bei CMU. Zunächst haben wir das Projekt auch irgendwann eingestellt und Harlequin wurde dann irgendwann auch verkauft und zerschlagen in viele Teile. Also eigentlich ist alles gestrandet, was in irgendeiner Form der Dylan-Entwicklung den Halt und die Finanzierung gegeben hat. Und dann seid ihr ja zunächst einmal auf die CMU-Community zugegangen, habt gesagt, was es mit dem Source-Code gibt, mal her.
Richtig? Na die haben den damals schon Open Source veröffentlicht. Also das Arbeitsergebnis, das gab da eine DARPA-Finanzierung für das Projekt und nachdem das Projekt abgeschlossen war, wurde halt der Code veröffentlicht und ist damit eingestellt. Und es ging eigentlich los, dass ich zusammen mit einem anderen Menschen angefangen habe, RPM-Pakete für diesen Compiler zu bauen. Und dann haben wir halt plötzlich irgendwie angefangen, da drin Bugs zu fixen. Und irgendwie war das dann halt unser Projekt und haben das dann auch irgendwann offiziell übergeben bekommen von der Carnegie Mellon Universität. Das war so 98 rum.
Daraus hat sich dann sozusagen auch der Name des Projektes begründet, weil das hieß ja dann Gewidion Dillon, ein Name, der nicht gleich von der Zunge geht. Warum heißt es Gewidion?
Weil ein gewisser Dillon, in der valisischen Mythologie vorkommt und da gibt es auch einen Gewidion und sie brachten halt einen Namen und dann haben sie das mal gelesen. Ist ja eigentlich ein schöner Name, nur leider schwierig zu sprechen und noch schwieriger zu merken, wie man ihn tippt und im Internet zu finden. Haben wir aber erstmal mitgeerbt, haben ja eine Weile eigentlich relativ regelmäßig Releases gemacht dieses Compilers, ihn weiterentwickelt, angepasst, wachsgefixt und so weiter und sofort. Nun ergab es sich aber vor, mittlerweile ist es schon zwei Jahre her, dass sich abzeichnet, dass aus der kommerziellen Nutzung des Harlekin-Dillens nicht wurde. Also Harlekin war schon vor einer Weile pleite gegangen, dann haben durch einen glücklichen Umstand die Programmierer es geschafft, die Rechte an den Compiler rauszukaufen. Man selber noch mal probiert, sich kommerziell über Wasser zu halten.
Hat aber auch nicht geklappt.
Hat auch nicht funktioniert. Und die haben dann vor zwei Jahren beschlossen, nachdem sie gesehen haben, das lief bei uns so gut, man kann den Leuten's-Housecode in die Hand drücken und die kümmern sich dann darum, dass er nicht verrottet, dass auch sie uns ihren's-Housecode zur Verfügung stellen. Das heißt, wir haben im Prinzip ein Compiler-Projekt geerbt, das über wirklich viele Jahre mit tatsächlich ausgewachsenen, professionellen Mitteln entwickelt wurde.
Wo auch Tausende von Mannstunden an Softwareentwicklung von klugen Leuten drinsteckt.
Ja, also ich würde grob schätzen 200 oder 300-Personen-Jahre-Entwicklung sind das schon, die wir da an's-Housecode haben. Also allein der Garbage-Collector sind 30-Personen-Jahre und der Rest ist nicht weniger. Und das waren alles auch Leute, die wie gesagt viel Erfahrung hatten, die aus der LISP-Compiler, LISP-Maschinenwelt kommen und eigentlich schon seit 10, 15, 20 Jahren einen Compiler geschrieben haben. Man sieht das dem Code auch an, also der ist auch, also gerade die Kernbereiche des Compilers sind wirklich sehr, sehr schön, sehr, sehr strukturiert hingeschrieben. Da findet man also wirklich bibliotheksweise keine Funktion, die länger als eine Bildschirmseite ist. Und das ist natürlich ein erhebliches Qualitätsmerkmal für Source Code, wenn man es schafft, die Sachen so zu gliedern, dass man sie kompakt ausdrücken kann. Wenn eine Funktion auf eine Bildschirmseite passt, dann kann man die auch mal durch hingucken verstehen und kann sich davon überzeugen, dass die auch backfrei ist und das tut, was sie soll, was man halt nicht kann, wenn man irgendwie 3000 Zeilen Monster-Spaghetti-Code-Funktionen hat.
Ja, ich denke, es wäre jetzt auch mal an der Zeit, ein bisschen darauf hinzuweisen, warum dieser ganze Aufwand, den ihr da getrieben habt, euch so wichtig war. Weil nun, das ist ja zunächst einmal yet another programming language, aber Dylan ist ja ein bisschen anders und Dylan bietet eine ganze Menge. Was sind denn so die wesentlichen Funktionalitäten, die die Programmiersprache bereitstellt, die jetzt diesen ganzen Aufwand so wertvoll machen? Weil man könnte ja auch sagen, na ja, es gibt ja Java, oder es gibt Python, oder es gibt Ruby, und JavaScript ist gerade mal wieder schön in Mode. Was haben diese Programmiersprachen alle nicht? Warum kann ich nicht einfach in C++ programmieren? Warum kann ich nicht auch einfach LISP weiternehmen? Was ist quasi der Grund, warum man eben so viel Energie in diese Sprache steckt?
Es ist schwierig, es auf den Punkt zu bringen, ohne eine längere Liste von Schlagwörtern auszupacken. Also Dylan ist eine objektorientierte, dynamisch typisierte Sprache mit Higher Order Functions, automatischem Memory-Management. Es hat eine strikte Typisierung und ja, noch so zwei oder drei andere Sprach-Features, die relativ wichtig und relativ interessant sind.
Also mit anderen Worten ist es komplett Buzzword-compliant.
Es ist vollständig Buzzword-compliant, das auf jeden Fall. Ich denke, was so das Besondere ist, was Dylan wirklich relativ einmalig macht, ist, dass es die Mächtigkeit und die Einfachheit von dynamischen Sprachen, also was man gemeinhin auch Skript-Sprachen nennt, ohne dass eine Skript-Sprache eine feste Definition hat, verbindet mit der Performance, die man halt aus einer statisch typisierten, kompilierten Programmiersprache rausholen kann.
Also es gibt da, wie z.B. C oder C++.
Wie C++, wie auch Java und andere Sprachen.
Ihr habt ja die Sprache ja auch durchaus schon erfolgreich zur Anwendung gebracht. Ihr habt ja jetzt ein paar Mal an dem ICFP teilgenommen. Was war noch kurz die genaue Auflösung dieses agronyms?
ICFP, der ICFP-Contest.
International Contest.
ICFP ist die International Conference for Functional Programming. Das ist also eine wissenschaftliche Konferenz der ACM, Association of Computing Machineries, so dem größten, naja, wie drückt man sich aus, sondern dass es allzu negativ klingt, dass sie Geld für ihre wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse haben wollen. So ein Wissenschaftsverband, die Konferenzen abhalten und dann Proceedings rausgeben. Und man veröffentlicht einfach bei der ACM, wenn man irgendwie in dem alten Denkmodell noch drin steckt. Die ICFP ist eine von zwei, drei, vier Konferenzen, die sie zum Thema Programmiersprachen haben, die sich halt mit, vor allen Dingen, funktionaler Programmierung beschäftigt. Und die haben seit einiger Zeit zu ihrer Konferenz einen Programmierwettbewerb, wo Teams dann 72 Stunden Zeit haben, um eine Aufgabe zu lösen. Also das Ganze funktioniert dezentral im Internet. Man bekommt die Aufgabe gestellt. Und die Aufgabe ist so komplex und schwierig, dass es keine korrekte Lösung gibt. Also es gibt da nicht irgendwie dann 8 von 10 Punkten für Aufgabe 3 oder so, sondern man muss halt ein Programm schreiben, das eine bestimmte Sache macht. Und diese Programme treten dann gegen die von den anderen geschriebenen Programmen an. Also das waren so Sachen wie, man muss einen Rätresser schreiben, wo dann halt die Zeit bewertet wurde, die das Programm braucht, um das Ergebnis zu liefern und ob die Pixel ein Ordnung waren. Oder sehr beliebt sind natürlich immer Spiele, die man mit dem Computer spielen kann, wo dann auf irgendwelche labiranten Roboter gegeneinander fahren.
Das war so das Thema vom letzten Mal, Räuber und Gendarm, richtig?
Ja, das mit den Robotern tauchte häufiger auf. Aber irgendwie beim letzten Mal waren es Roboter, die Räuber und Gendarm gespielt haben. Wir nehmen mit dem Dillen-Hackers-Team seit 2000 regelmäßig dran teil. Wir haben es bis jetzt schon dreimal geschafft, auf den vorderen Plätzen zu landen. Wir haben 2001 den zweiten Platz belegt, 2003 den Jurypreis bekommen und 2005 dann den zweiten Platz und den Jurypreis.
Und ihr seid ja auch nicht ohne Konkurrenz. Wie viele Teams nehmen daran teil?
Also jetzt 2005 haben 163 Teams teilgenommen.
Mit allen möglichen Programmiersprachen.
Mit allen möglichen Programmiersprachen, ja. Es ist also nicht so, dass das begrenzt wäre auf funktionale Sprachen, sondern man kann da mit der Sprache seiner Wahl dran teilnehmen. Und es gab also eine bunte Mischung. Interessant sind dann die Graphen zu sehen, wie viele Leute eingereicht haben, wie viele davon sich überhaupt funktionierten von den Programmen, die eingereicht wurden und wie viele davon dann die Qualifikation geschafft haben. Also die Regeln sind ziemlich strikt. Wenn das Programm crasht, fliegt man halt raus. Wenn das Programm einen falschen Output liefert, der nicht der Spezifikation entspricht, wird man disqualifiziert.
Zeitüberschreitungen?
Zeitüberschreitungen. Also wenn man länger als fünf Sekunden braucht, um in dem nächsten Spiel zu berechnen. Die Anforderungen sind schon relativ hart. Also man kann sich da keine Bugs erlauben. Wenn man einen Bug in seinem Programm hat, kann man es auch gleich vergessen. Dementsprechend sahen die Kurven für die C-Leute aus. Es gab glaube ich 40 Teams, die in C geschrieben haben. Davon haben 39 die Qualifikationen nicht geschafft.
Oha.
es gab eine Vorrunde und eine Ausscheidung. In der Vorrunde musste man gegen von den Richtern geschriebenen Teams antreten. Und die Roboter, gegen die man spielen musste, waren halt wirklich doof. Also wenn man in der Lage war, eine Strategie zu fahren, die besser war als random, dann hat man auch die Qualifikation geschafft. Interessanterweise haben von den 163 Teams genau 13 es geschafft, in die nächste Runde zu kommen, wo dann also die einzelnen Teams gegeneinander gespielt haben.
13 von 163 Teams haben es überhaupt geschafft, die erste Runde zu nehmen. Genau, überhaupt etwas die Qualifikation überhaupt erst mal gegen die anderen antreten zu dürfen.
Genau, so was wie, es crasht nicht, es liefert ordentlich Antworten und das Verhalten des Programms ist irgendwie gut genug, um einen wirklichen Trivial-Algorithmus zu schlagen, also besser als random.
Und es läuft schnell genug, um eine Antwort zu formulieren.
Genau.
Okay, 13. Und da war alles dabei. Es war Pearl dabei, es war Java dabei, es war C, C++ dabei.
Ja, das ist eine Sprache, die relativ viel vertreten ist. Natürlich ist zwei eigentlich Heskel und Okaml. Das sind so die beiden Familien von funktionalen Sprachen, also von statisch getübten funktionalen Sprachen, mit denen sie Wissenschaft zu beschäftigen.
Die waren nicht stark vertreten bei den 163, sondern die waren stark vertreten bei den 13, die es geschafft haben.
Sowohl als auch, aber der Anteil, der die Qualifikation geschafft hat, war höher. Das waren schon durchaus mehr.
Und dann das eine Düllenteam.
Das eine Düllenteam, genau. Mit der einen Einreichung.
Okay, und dann in der zweiten Runde?
Ja, in der zweiten Runde wurden dann die Teams gegeneinander losgelassen. Die Spielregeln sahen es halt vor, dass immer sechs Teams gleichzeitig spielen. Die wurden halt so lange in random Pools aufeinander geworfen, bis halt eine stabile Ordnung zwischen den Teams da war. Ja, da sind wir halt von der Punktwertung auf den zweiten Platz gekommen, geschlagen von einem Team, das Haskell verwendet hat. Wobei, also wir hätten auch problemlos den ersten erreichen können. Es gab dieses Mal eine kleine Modifikation. Man musste halt drei Tage programmieren. Nach 14 Tagen wurden die Regeln geändert und man musste sein Programm anpassen an die neuen Regeln. Und wir haben halt bei der Auswahl einer passenden Strategie, die den neuen Regeln entgegenkommt, versagt. Also entsprechend der Auswertung haben wir alles falsch gemacht, was falsch zu machen war unter den neuen Regeln. Wir haben es dann trotzdem nur auf den zweiten Platz geschafft. Ja, und den Jurypreis haben wir für das lesbarste Programm gewonnen.
Na ja, ich dachte, das ging um Reviews.
Ja, das hat mit Lesbarkeit zu tun. Also der schönste Code-Reviews ist das beste, wie vorher, nachher. Wie wurde die Änderung? Also wie groß war der Impact der Regeländerung auf die Änderung der Code-Basis? Bei uns war es halt so, dass es sauber abstrahiert war und deswegen sich eigentlich relativ wenig geändert hat an dem Code. Also nur an da, wo wirklich die Regeln anders waren, mussten wir was anfassen. Nicht etwa überall durchgehen, alles anders machen. Und wir waren da wohl besser als alle anderen.
Okay, also es macht durchaus den Eindruck, dass man in Düllen funktionierende Programme schreiben kann, die auch in der Lage sind, gegen einen Großteil der Programmiersprachen da draußen in einem definierten Contest zu bestehen. Dann sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen, ich hab's jetzt auch bewusst, ein bisschen nach hinten geschoben, damit die Leute, die bis jetzt zugehört haben, die Metathematik auf jeden Fall schon haben, in sich aufnehmen können. Aber jetzt müssen wir natürlich auch gerade für die Programmierer unter den Hörern auch nochmal ein bisschen draufblicken, was denn jetzt eigentlich die Programmiersprache konkret ausmacht und was vor allem die Unterschiede ausmacht. Wir haben uns ja auch ein paar Sachen mal rausgesucht. Was würdest du denn da als erstes erwähnenswert finden?
Wir können ja die Basswörz der Reihe nach durchgehen. Also es fängt mit objektorientiert an. Bei LISP ist es so, dass das mit den Objekten später kam. Es gab also am Anfang die fundamentalen Typen, sowas wie integer und character und stringen. Und dann gab es Objekttypen irgendwann, als mal das Objektmodell dazugestrickt wurde. LISP war halt gut genug, dass man das mit den Objekten einfach mal links dran kleben konnte. Aber trotzdem ist es so, dass halt nicht alles eine Instanz eines Objektes ist. Bei Java ist es ja auch nicht anders heutzutage. Da hat man dann irgendwie Integers und Objekte und dann hat man sogar zwei Integer, weil es gibt einen, der als Objekt präsentiert ist und einen Native Integer. Und man ist am Konvertieren und so weiter und so fort. Das wurde bei Dylan mal abgeschafft. Das heißt, alles ist eine Instanz einer Klasse. Also das Objektsystem ist auch klassenbasiert, nicht prototypbasiert wie bei JavaScript zum Beispiel.
Das heißt, man schafft sich mit der Klasse im Prinzip arten und weisen und schafft dann eben konkrete Objekte, die sich in irgendeiner Form verhalten. Und hat dieses typische Vererbungsmodell. Das heißt, eine Klasse kann eine Unterklasse haben und eine Unterklasse übernimmt im Wesentlichen das Verhalten der Überklasse.
Man hat ein Vererbungsmodell. Objektorientierungen sind eigentlich so zwei Eigenschaften, die da zusammenkommen. Das eine ist das mit der Vererbung und das andere ist das mit der Polymorphie. Das mit der Vererbung ist relativ einfach erklärt. Das ist eine Ist-Einbeziehung. So was wie eine Banane isst ein Stück Obst und ein Stück Obst isst ein Lebensmittel. Und Polymorphie heißt eigentlich, dass man Dinge auf der Abstraktionsebene betrachtet, auf der man sich gerne betrachten will. Das heißt, wenn ich über Lebensmittel rede und dann plötzlich eine Banane in der Hand halte, dann funktioniert das, weil eine Banane ein Lebensmittel ist. Und alles, was ich über Lebensmittel aussage, ist auch für eine Banane wahr. Also ich kann in meinem Code hinschreiben, wenn du Hunger hast, geh was essen. Und wenn dann zufällig eine Banane rumliegt, dann ist sozusagen der Computer in der Lage, mit der Instruktion ist, was klarzukommen.
Genau, nur wie man das Obst dann öffnet, dann wird dann eben der spezifische Ansatz für das jeweilige Objekt.
Das ist dann spezifisch. Also dieses verschiedene Verhalten von den Objekten wird über polymorphe Funktionen erreicht. Das ist eine Stelle, die für Leute, die in den in Anführungszeichen klassischen objektorientierten Sprachen schon mal programmiert haben, ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig ist. Zumal Objektorientierung oftmals nicht so erklärt wird, wie ich das gerade getan habe, sondern mit, naja, so eine Klasse, das ist halt irgendwie, da schweift man eine geschweifte Klammer auf und dann schreibt man alle Daten hin, dann schreibt man alle Methoden von dieser Klasse hin, so die Vorstellung, dass eine Klasse eigentlich so Code und Daten kapselt. Das kann man machen, ist aber nur ein Subset dessen, was mit generischer Polymorphie möglich ist. Die Dylan hat also diesen Ansatz, Methoden sind Bestandteil der Klassen nicht, sondern zieht die Funktionen raus und sagt irgendwie, Objekte und Funktionen sind beides gleichberechtigte Dinge, die nebeneinander stehen. Das ist in der natürlichen Sprache auch so. Da gibt es auch Verben und Objekte, die gleichberechtigt sind. Es gibt da also den Begriff der generischen Funktion.
Also muss man kurz festhalten, ein Hauptunterschied zwischen Dylan und den allermeisten objektorientierten Programmiersprachen ist der, dass die Methoden nicht Teil der Klassenspezifikation sind. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendetwas beschreibe wie eine Banane, ein Obst oder was auch immer, dann konzentriere ich mich eigentlich eher nur auf die grundlegenden Attribute. Was sind die Eigenschaften dieses Objektes? Was muss ich speichern? Aber das, wie gehe ich damit um, ist separat davon. Das heißt, das Öffnen einer Banane, das Essen einer Banane, das ist alles etwas, was nicht innerhalb der Klassendefinition ist, wie man es erwarten würde, wenn man mit C++-Gedanken gut daran geht oder mit Java ansetzen, das ist halt nicht der Fall. Was nicht heißt, dass man es nicht kapseln kann, weil man kann ja dann immer noch alles in ein Modul schmeißen, aber zunächst einmal ist es in der Sprache unterschiedlich. Ja, und das ist ja dann auch in Dülen bis sehr konsequent durchgesetzt worden. Das heißt, da die Methode nicht mehr in der Klasse ist und sich außerhalb befindet, muss man ja trotzdem irgendwie den Bezug herstellen. Und man will ja dann sozusagen unter einem Namen eine Funktionalität für viele unterschiedliche Objekte haben.
Genau, also was einem auch immer wieder erzählt wird bei objektorientierter Programmierung ist, dass es etwas mit Kapselungen zu tun hat. Das ist zwar eigentlich nur begrenzt richtig, aber trotzdem ist Kapselung natürlich etwas, was man haben will. Und Kapselungen, wie du schon erwähnt hast, wird über Module realisiert. Das heißt, irgendwie das, was eine Klasse ist, in C++ wird eigentlich in Klassen generische Funktionen und Module, die diese beiden Sachen enthalten, auseinander genommen. Was man jetzt erklären muss, es klingt erst mal so, als wäre das nur so ein oberflächliches, syntaktisches Feature. Man schreibt das halt anders hin. Ist es aber nicht. Sondern was dahinter steckt, diese generischen Funktionen sind einfach ein mächtigerer Ansatz, um die richtige Methode auszuwählen, um Dinge zu tun. Für die Leute, die es schon mal gehört haben, kann man hier mal das Visitor-Pattern nennen. Wenn das, was man tun will, abhängig ist nicht nur von einem Objekt, sondern von dem Typ von zwei Objekten. Ein ganz einfaches Beispiel, ich möchte A plus B rechnen. Nun lernt man ja in der Grundschule das mit dem Plus, und dann lernt man später das mit dem Plus nochmal, wenn das mit den Brüchen kommt und das mit den Nachkommastellen. Dann ist es eigentlich so, dass jedes Plus irgendwie anders funktioniert. Also eine Ganzzahl plus eine Ganzzahl funktioniert so, und ein Ganzzahl plus ein Bruch funktioniert anders, und ein Bruch plus eine Fließkommazahl funktioniert nochmal anders. Und dann hat man irgendwann Matrizen, und dann will man vielleicht auch noch eigene Sachen einführen, auf denen man rechnen kann.
Aber man schreibt halt immer Plus, und man denkt halt auch immer irgendwie Plus.
Man denkt A plus B, und sowohl A als auch B kann halt irgendwas sein. Und wenn man jetzt so dieses klassische Single-Dispatch-Modell, also eine virtuelle Funktion in C++ hat, dann schreibt man ja immer Objekt, Punkt, Funktion, Klammer auf, die weiteren Argumente. Und welche der Punkt-Funktion aufgerufen wird, also welche der Funktionen bei einer virtuellen Funktion hängt nur von dem A ab, nicht von den Argumenten, die hinten noch übergeben werden. Also um es noch präziser auszudrücken, nicht von dem Laufzeit-Typ, sondern von dem Kompilzeit-Typ. Und also man merkt es halt, wenn man versucht, sowas wie A plus B zu implementieren, da gibt es in C++ zwar Operator-Overloading, was ein bisschen so aussieht wie generische Funktionen, nur dass es mit dem Kompilzeit-Typ passiert, nicht mit dem tatsächlichen Laufzeit-Typ. Und man fällt damit ganz furchtbar auf die Fresse, wenn man sich seinen Plus definiert hat und dann so eine Funktionen Square hinschreibt. Und dann hinschreibt ja Square von Number A und Number B ist halt A mal B. Und das C++ aber gar nicht weiß, dass es jetzt irgendwie abhängig, also wenn A ein Integer ist und B in einen Bruch, dass es dann was anderes aufrufen muss, weil es nur auf den Compiletime-Typ guckt. Und das ist etwas, wo man sehr viel Mächtigkeit gewinnt.
Das heißt, diese ganzen Entscheidungen werden bei Dylan eben zur Laufzeit gefällt? Alles wird konkret erst in dem Moment entschieden, wenn das Programm an der Stelle angekommen ist?
Na zumindest wird der Anschein gewahrt. Es ist natürlich so, dass wenn man alles zur Laufzeit tut, es ziemlich langsam ist. Und Dylan zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass es über einen Mechanismus verfügt, der so genanntes Optimistic Type Inferencing macht. Und wo dann die Entscheidung, welche der Methoden jetzt aufgerufen wird, auch zur Compiletime gemacht wird, wenn der Compiler ausreichend viel Typinformation darüber hat.
Aber das ist halt nichts, worüber ich als Programmierer nachdenken muss?
Da musst du erst drüber nachdenken, wenn du Performance-Optimierung machst. Da musst du bei der Struktur des Programms nicht nachdenken.
Das heißt, mit anderen Worten, umso mehr der Compiler von sich aus schon in der Lage ist, zu mutmaßen, was und welche Objektypen es sich hier konkret handelt, umso mehr kann er an der Stelle optimieren. Aber das macht er sozusagen schon mal von sich aus. Ich muss ihm da gar keine Tipps geben und ich muss vor allem auch keine Vorentscheidungen machen. Ich kann auch generell sagen, alles ist jetzt erstmal Object und ich schreibe hier meine Methoden hin und die arbeiten irgendwie mit Object. Dann ist das alles erstmal offen gelassen. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich Einschränkungen mache und sage, okay, hier habe ich jetzt nur Integers, hier habe ich nur Strings, dann kann der Compiler eben sagen, okay, alles prima, da weiß ich halt genau, was zu tun ist und dann läuft es entsprechend schneller.
Genau so ist das. Also nicht nur, dass es schneller läuft, sondern es wird auch garantiert, dass diese Überprüfung durchgeführt wird. Das heißt, es ist nicht möglich, sowas wie ein Cast gibt es in Dylan nicht. Man kann den Compiler nicht beschummeln bei den Typen. Und man kann dadurch, man kann sagen, let a gleich 3 mal 3. Und dann hat a erstmal keinen Typ und man kann dem a auch hinterher wieder ein String zuweisen oder eine Liste oder was auch immer man gerade an Objekten hat. Man kann aber alternativ auch hinschreiben, let a, Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt, Integer gleich 3. Und dann wird ein Typ-Check eingefügt, der überprüft, ob diese Zuweisung denn gültig ist. Und wenn sie nicht gültig ist, wird ein Fehler geworfen. Und der Compiler verwendet das, um die Typ das Type Inferencing zu machen und die Performance zu machen.
Weil an dem Moment darf es halt einfach nur ein Integer sein und nichts anderes.
Genau. Was dazu führt, dass man oftmals so entwickelt, dass man relativ schnell einen Prototype-Code schreibt, der dann stilistisch auch so aussieht, wie Code in Python oder Perl aussehen würde, also ohne Typen. Und dann irgendwann sich aber doch mal Gedanken um Typen macht. Und wenn man dann so eine Klassenhierarchie sich mal ausgedacht hat, die man braucht, dann kann man das auch nochmal hinschreiben und hat halt auf der einen Seite den Vorteil, dass es überprüft wird und auf der anderen Seite den Performance gewinnt dadurch, dass es schneller wird. Also man arbeitet dann auch so, dass man einfach das schreibt und wenn es funktioniert, macht man Profiling, dann sieht man wo die Hotspots sind, dann geht man da hin, schreibt ein paar Typen hin, dann ist das Programm schnell fertig.
Ok, jetzt wollte ich nochmal zurück auf diese Polymorphie, wo wir da eben gerade ausgeschert sind. Und du hast ja schon erwähnt, Single Dispatch ist das, wie die anderen Programmiersprachen das nennen bei Dylan, ist dann sozusagen der Multiple Dispatch, sprich in dem Moment, wo ich eine Methode aufrufe, entscheidet sich eigentlich erst, welche Methode dieses Namens ich aufrufe. Das heißt, ich schreibe in meinem Programm mehrere Varianten einer Methode, die immer unter demselben Namen filmiert. Und das ist quasi diese generische Funktion.
Genau.
Die generische Funktion ist erstmal der Name. Es gibt den Vorgang öffne und dann schreibe ich halt den Fall öffne im Fall einer Dose, ich schreibe öffne im Fall einer Banane. Und irgendwo in meinem Programm rufe ich halt auf, öffne dieses Objekt, was hier gerade um die Straßenecke gekommen ist und dann entscheidet der Compiler quasi zur Laufzeit. Und wenn er halt genug Daten schon vorher hat, dass er das einschränken kann, unter Umständen auch schon zur Übersetzungszeit, aber spätestens zur Laufzeit, dass jetzt an dieser Stelle die Methode für den Fall Banane oder für den Fall Obst vielleicht auch nur aufgerufen wird und im anderen Fall eben für die Dose.
Der große Vorteil, wenn man generische Funktionen und Klassen voneinander koppelt, ist auch der, dass man wesentlich modulareren Code schreiben kann. Also es passiert einem bei Single Dispatch oft, dass man halt eine Funktion implementiert und dann in der Funktion doch wieder ein großes If-Statement macht, wo man sich den tatsächlichen Typ anguckt von dem, was man bekommen ist. Das heißt, mit Instance-Off in Java zum Beispiel oder mit Dynamic Cast in C++ oder RTTI oder ähnlich schlimme Tricks. Und das hat natürlich einen großen Nachteil, weil in dem Moment, wo man ein weiteres Objekt hinzufügt, muss man alle anderen Klassendefinitionen anfassen und muss da in dieses If-Statement einen weiteren else-if Zweig mit dem neu dazugekommenen Typ reinmachen. Und das ist natürlich in keinster Weise modular. Da hat man Spaghetti-Code. Und diese Trennung der beiden ermöglicht es einem halt zu, auch in einer Klassenhierarchie, einer Library, die man importiert hat, eine neue Funktion hinzuzufügen, auf der dann dispatched wird.
Vorhin hast du noch erwähnt, dass es Higher Order Functions gibt in Dylan. Was ist das?
Das sind Funktionen, die Funktionen als Argumente bekommen. Funktionen in Dylan sind ganz normale Objekte, die man genauso zuweisen und herumreichen und an Funktionen übergeben kann, wie alle anderen Objekte auch.
Da sind wir wieder beim Lambda-Kalkül?
Wir sind da wieder ein Stückchen beim Lambda-Kalkül. Da kommt das alles her. Der Fachterminus dafür ist First Class Function. Das heißt, Funktionen sind Instanzen erster Klasse. Das heißt, ganz genauso gleichberechtigt wie alle anderen Objektinstanzen auch.
Also überall, wo ich mit einer 5 und einem String um mich werfen kann, kann ich auch einfach Funktionen reinspeisen. Ich kann Funktionen in meine Listen reinsortieren. Ich kann alles damit tun.
Und das ist auch etwas, was erlaubt, abstrakteren Code zu schreiben, weil man zum Beispiel Algorithmen parametrisieren kann. Man kann sowas machen wie, hier ist mal eine Funktion, die über einen Baum drüber läuft und übrigens für jedes Element des Baumes ruft mal die als Parameter übergebende Funktion auf. Man kann damit das eigentliche Arbeiten vom über dem Baum laufen trennen. Man kann es auch relativ elegant hinschreiben.
So Sortierentscheidungen zum Beispiel.
Genau. Man spart sich damit auch oftmals, eine längere Vorschleife hinzuschreiben und kann Sachen sehr kompakt ausdrücken. Also zum Beispiel, um alle Elemente einer Liste zusammen zu addieren, kann man die Funktion Reduce verwenden. Reduce nennt halt eine Funktion, sagen wir mal, Plus als Argument und eine Liste, sagen wir mal, 1, 2, 3. Und rechnet dann 1 plus 2, merkt sich das Zwischenergebnis 3, rechnet dann 3 plus 3, hat dann 6 und gibt 6 als gesandten Wert zurück. Es gibt auch anonyme Funktionen, das was in Common Lisp Lambda heißt, was bei Dylan einfach Method heißt. Man muss einer Funktion nicht unbedingt einen Namen geben, sondern man kann sie auch einfach hinschreiben. Das heißt, wenn man es Reduce schreibt, kann man auch sagen, Reduce Klammer auf, Method von X, Fubar, End.
So kann man also auch in einer Funktion einfach eine neue Funktion erzeugen und diese Funktion auch als Ergebnis der Funktion zurückliefern.
Das kann man machen.
Und da gibt es quasi so eine Maschine, die Funktionen erzeugt.
Eine Maschine, die Funktionen erzeugt. Und da gibt es dann noch ein Detail, das nennt sich Closures. Die Funktion, die man da erzeugt, kann auch Variablen referenzieren aus der Funktion, die die Funktion mal erzeugt hat. Und merkt sich die in der Kopie. Das heißt, man kann sozusagen parametrisierte Funktionen erzeugen.
Nach dem Motto erzeuge mir mal eine Funktion, die eine bestimmte Funktionalität mit diesen Parametern macht. Und dann kriege ich diese Funktion zurück. Weiß gar nicht, wie die intern aussieht, aber ich weiß zumindest, mit welchen Parametern ich sie mal bestückt habe. Hab die dann auch in so einer Variablen gespeichert und kann die dann jederzeit aus meinem Säckchen auspacken, wenn ich die brauche und dann auf irgendwas losfeuern?
Genau. Fach aufrufen, die kennt dann ihre Parameter, die mal bei der Funktion sozusagen reingesteckt wurden. Das sind Closures.
Was ja auch noch ein Unterschied ist bei den Funktionen, die ich eigentlich ganz elegant finde, ist, dass natürlich eine Funktion nicht nur einen Rückgabewert haben kann bei Dylan, sondern mehrere.
Genau, man kann, also ähnlich wie man beliebig viele Argumente übergeben kann an eine Funktion, kann man auch beliebig viele Rückgabewerte bekommen. Das ist etwas, was andere Sprachen teilweise auch haben, also in Perl sieht man das gelegentlich, was ja sehr nützlich ist, weil sowas wie eine Division zum Beispiel kann man problemlos das Ergebnis der Division und den Rest der Division zurückgeben, braucht man auch ständig. Andere Sprachen, also in C übergibt man dann immer Pointer auf Output-Parameter, was dann den schweren Nachteil hat, dass einige der Funktionsargumente Inputs und einige der Funktionsargumente Outputs sind und einer der Outputs dann nochmal extra gehandelt wird, nämlich als den eigentlichen Rückgabewert. Und deshalb eigentlich wesentlich eleganter, wenn man das in ein Konstrukt einpackt. Funktionen haben auch noch ein paar andere nette Features, wie zum Beispiel Keyword-Arguments, das heißt Argumente, die optional sind und die mit einem Schlüsselwort benannt werden. Das heißt, man kann dann schreiben Funktionsaufruf Foo 23,42 und diese Keyword-Parameter sind optional und können auch in beliebiger Reihenfolge hingeschrieben werden.
Also im Prinzip so wie die Optionen auf der Kommandozeile von Programmen, die man startet, die man auch weglassen kann und die dann einen sinnvollen Default haben, kann man das genauso bei den Funktionen auch machen. Und natürlich auch beliebig viele Parameter. Also wenn man sagt, und hier können jetzt nochmal N Parameter kommen, und man muss sich auch nicht unter Umständen um den Typ kümmern, weil da liegen dann halt einfach nochmal 5 und dann nimmt man die halt einfach mit auf. Also ein ähnlicher Komfort wie jetzt bei den Funktionen mit diesen Keywords, die gibt es ja auch, wenn man eine Klasse erstellt. Also man kann da auch bestimmte Defaults angeben. Kannst du da noch was zu sagen?
Ja, es ist sehr bequem, eine Klasse zu definieren, weil man für viele Standardfälle von Initialisierungen, in Dylan heißen sie Slots, das was man bei C++ als Member kennt, also die eigentlichen Datenelemente in so einer Klasse drin. Man spart sich damit in der Regel das Schreiben eines Konstruktors. Das heißt, man kann einen Default-Wert angeben für einen Slot. Man kann angeben, dass bei der Erzeugung der Klasse mit einem Keyword-Argument ein Initialwert übergeben werden kann. Man kann auch sagen, dass er übergeben werden muss. Man kann eine Funktion angeben, die einen Init-Wert berechnen. Und kann damit also schon sehr, sehr viel gestalten. Die Objekterzeugung ist auch sehr interessant. Und zwar werden Objekte über Make angelegt. Man sagt also Make und übergibt dann die Klasse. Make Banana, Color Doppelpunkt Yellow. Macht mir eine gelbe Banane. Das, was in anderen Sprachen ein Konstruktor ist, ist da eigentlich in zwei Teile geteilt. Es gibt einmal das Make. Aber Make ist eher so was wie ein Abstract Factory Interface. Auch wieder für die Leute, die die Patternbücher gelesen haben. Das heißt, man sagt, was man haben möchte. Man sagt, man will eine Banane. Und jetzt ist Make aber nicht gezwungen, eine konkrete Instanz, eine Banane zurückzuliefern. Vielleicht ist es interessanter, wenn man den Fall betrachtet. Man sagt, Make fruit, mach mir mal Obst. Und dann kann nämlich Make entscheiden. Hm, er hat nicht gesagt, was er will. Ich hab hier noch Bananen rumzuliegen. Ich geb ihm mal eine Banane. Also man bekommt eine nicht näher spezifizierte Subklasse von dem, was man haben will, geliefert.
Oder wenn ich Make Banana sage, kann er mir halt eine gelbe Banane geben oder kann mir so eine Kochbanane liefern.
Genau, was auch immer er... Also quasi das, was halt ein Abstract Factory-Interface macht. Man kann da halt einen beliebigen Algorithmus implementieren, der den konkreten Typ auswählt, der inszenziert wird. Und man kann auch eine bereits existierende Instanz zurückliefern von Make. Also wenn man so was wie einen Singleton-Pattern implementiert, dann guckt man halt in Make nach, ob man schon mal so ein Objekt erzeugt hat. Und liefert dann immer dasselbe zurück. Der zweite Schritt bei der Objekterzeugung ist dann Initialize. Und das ist wirklich die konkrete Initialisierung eines konkreten Objektes. Also wenn Make sich mal entschlossen hat, dann doch eine frische Instanz zu erzeugen und den Speicher dafür bereitgestellt hat, dann wird in Initialize die Klasse mit Daten befüllt. Und da gibt es natürlich eine Default-Methode, die die ganzen beschriebenen tollen Features mit Default-Werten und Keyword-Argumenten unterstützt, wo man aber auch overriden kann, wo man also noch zusätzlich Berechnungen machen kann, wenn da Dependencies existieren, um seine Klasse auszufüllen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das vorhin schon erwähnt haben, aber das Klassenmodell von Dylan erlaubt ja auch Mehrfach-Vererbung. Mehrfach-Vererbung ist ja etwas, was immer sehr umstritten ist. Wenn man das erwähnt, dass ja viele Programmiersprachen das nicht hätten, also C++ hat es, aber Java zum Beispiel hat es nicht. Und da gibt es dann immer gerne dieses Argument, wenn man fragt, warum habt ihr denn das nicht, dann gibt es dieses Argument, ja das ist ja alles total kompliziert, und dann kann man ja auch bestimmte Fälle nicht entscheiden. Dylan hat es. Ist es kompliziert da?
Es ist nicht kompliziert. In C++ ist es kompliziert, weil es verschiedene Arten und Weisen gibt. Was passiert, wenn man dieselbe Klasse auf mehreren Wegen erbt? Also es kann dann passieren, man leitet irgendwie von Obst ab, man leitet von zylindrischem Objekt ab, und beides ist aber eine Instanz eines physikalischen Objektes, das irgendwie eine Masse und einen Schwerpunkt und eine Dimension und sowas hat. Und was passiert denn jetzt, wenn man dieselbe Klasse auf zwei Wegen erbt, hat man dann einmal oder zweimal den Slot, der da drin steckt, also die Member in C++-Terminologie. Und in C++ gibt es Virtual Inheritance. Das ist dann die Stelle, wo sogar die meisten C++-Programmierer anfangen, große Augen zu machen, weil sie in ihrem Leben noch nicht gehört haben.
Ich muss sagen, davon hab ich auch noch nie was gehört.
Das ist halt so, wie es Dylan macht. Also wenn man irgendwas auf zwei Wegen erbt, dann ist es hinterher bloß einmal in der Klasse. Und es gibt aber halt auch noch das andere. Und das macht das alles unheimlich komplex. Und dann hat man das Problem, dass die Adresse von Slots in der Klasse, also jetzt in der Implementierung, sich ändern können, je nachdem, auf welchem Weg man geerbt hat. Das heißt, man hat keine feste Adresse mehr. Und es ist auch schwierig zu implementieren. Man muss nachdenken, wenn man seinen Compiler schreibt. Das sind so die Gründe, warum das bei dem Design von Java weggelassen wurde. Und es fehlt aber wirklich schmerzlich, weil Multiple Inheritance es erlaubt, sogenannte Mixins zu schreiben. Das heißt, wenn man eine bestimmte Funktionalität in seiner Klasse will, dann leitet man zusätzlich von der einen oder anderen Klasse ab, die genau dieses Feature bereitstellt. So was wie Cueable fällt mir jetzt ein.
Genau, da wollte ich mir auch gerade mal drauf sprechen kommen, weil es gibt ja, Dylan kommt ja nicht nackt daher, sondern es gibt ja auch die Dylan, wie heißt die Standard Library? Die Dylan Library, genau. Das heißt, ein großes Paket an vorgefertigten Klassen und Objektsstrukturen und unter anderem auch ein sehr mächtiges Paket für Collections, also für alles Mögliche, was man in irgendeiner Form Objekte gruppieren. Listen, Hashtables, Strings im weiteren Sinne. Und dort wird ja an ganz vielen Stellen auch genau von diesem Schema Gebrauch gemacht. Also man hat Mehrfach-Vererbung quasi an der Stelle auch gleich in der Standard-Library in reger Benutzung. Und bei den Strings werden ja genau diese Mix-In-Ansätze verfolgt, oder?
Genau, also ein Beispiel dafür sind also erstmal Collections-Unterscheide zwischen Sequences und Tables. Das heißt, Sequences sind halt solche, die mit einem Index von 0 bis N adressiert werden. Und Tables sind eigentlich Hashtables. Und innerhalb der Sequence gibt es dann so Subklassen wie Mutable Sequence. Das sind also solche Sequenzen, wo Elemente geändert werden können. Oder es gibt Stretchy Sequences, die also größer und kleiner werden können. Und dann gibt es Strings, und Strings haben dann halt Characters als Elemente. Und dann gibt es Strings, die wachsen können, dann gibt es Strings, die man ändern kann, Strings, die man nicht ändern kann. Man kann sich dann also die entsprechenden Eigenschaften der Collection, die man haben will, eigentlich entsprechend zusammenstellen.
Genau, und das erreicht man dann durch diese Mix-Ins, sind sozusagen einfach Fähigkeiten. Und man findet dann eigentlich einen anderen Ansatz. Das heißt, man programmiert im Prinzip Verhalten in zunehmendem Maße, kann dieses Verhalten auch auf eine Klasse abbilden, indem man halt Methoden schreibt, die auf bestimmte Klassen eben spezifiziert sind. Und diese Klassen drücken im Prinzip nur eine bestimmte Eigenschaft aus. Und in dem Moment, wo ich mir dann ein konkretes Objekt zusammenbaue, kann ich eben dieses Verhalten, was durch diese Methoden implementiert wird, einfach dadurch herein importieren, diese Funktionalität mit aufnehmen, ohne dass ich eine Zeitcode schreiben muss, indem ich sage, okay, hier habe ich jetzt meine neue tolle Klasse, und die ist grundsätzlich erstmal eine Subklasse von und die holt aber dann auch noch die Fähigkeit sowieso rein, sowieso, sowieso, sowieso und sowieso. Kann irgendwie Radioaktivität abstrahlen, kann irgendwie Lieder singen und keine Ahnung, was mir da jetzt noch einfällt. Mit guten Beispielen ist das ja immer so eine Sache. Ich weiß nicht, ob du noch ein tolles Beispiel hast dafür.
Ich wollte was zu dem Wort Mix-Ins erzählen. Weißt du, woher Mix-Ins kommt?
Nicht wirklich. Also gibt es da eine bestimmte Geschichte?
Ja, da gibt es eine Geschichte zu. Das Dylan-Objektsystem ist hervorgegangen aus Kloss, dem Common-Lisp-Object-System. Kloss hatte einen Vorleufer, der hieß Flavours. Es war so, dass die Lisp-Hacker regelmäßig Eis essen gegangen sind. Da gab es Eis in verschiedenen Geschmacksrichtungen. Zusätzlich gab es Möglichkeiten, da Mix-Ins reißen zu machen. Man konnte Vanille-Eis, Schoko-Eis, Fruchteis, und dann konnte man sich kleinen gehacktes Smarties darunter mixen lassen. Mix-Ins oder mit Schokoladenüberzug oder mit Sahne obendrauf und sich halt das zusammenstellen, wie man das braucht.
Man merkt ja an vielen Stellen, dass einfach diese Dylan und Lisp-Gemeinde zusammenhängen. Wie war das noch gleich mit diesem Editor? EMAX ist ja nun ein sehr bekanntes Projekt, was aus dieser Lisp-Community hervorgegangen ist. Und dann, ich kriege das wieder nicht zusammen, da gab es den eine und dann gab es den zweiten.
Genau, es gab eine und zwei. Also die Geschichte ist noch ein bisschen länger. EMAX hat ja mal angefangen als Satz von Makros für Tekko. Tekko war ein ganz grauenhafter Editor auf Multics. Der Sport war zu raten, was passiert, wenn man seinen Namen eingibt in Tekko als Kommando. Einbuchstabige Kommandos, wie AI, bloß noch ein bisschen komplizierter.
Man tippt einfach mal drauf los und guckt, was passiert.
Genau. Und Tekko war seitenorientiert. Man hat immer aus der zu bearbeitenden Datei 24 Zeilen eingeladen, konnte die editieren, dann wieder rausschreiben und dann die nächsten 24 Zeilen. Dann kam irgendjemand mal auf die Idee, den Screen-Editor zu erfinden. Also ein Editor, wo man das gesamte Dokument am Stück bearbeitet. Auch sowas musste man erfinden. Es gab mal einen Punkt in der Geschichte, da gab es das vorher nicht. Das hat sich dann jemand ausgedacht und das war Emacs. Und Emacs wurde dann nochmal neu geschrieben. Und zwar mit Mac Lisp, das war der Multics Common Lisp-Compiler. Und Common, nicht Common Lisp, das war V-Common Lisp, der Multics Lisp-Compiler. Und da war halt sowohl die Implementierungssprache für den Editor als auch die Erweiterungssprache für den Editor Lisp. Aus diesem ganzen System ist eigentlich, also Editor plus Compiler, das Betriebssystem für die Lisp-Maschinen hervorgegangen. Und auch Emacs wurde dann mehrfach neu geschrieben, die nächste Generation von Emacs, noch am MIT, auf der Lisp-Maschine, da im MIT entwickelt wurde, war eine. Eine steht für eine is not Emacs. Später bei Symbolics gab es für die Lisp-Maschinen einen weiteren Rewrite dieses Editors, der hieß dann zwei. Und zwei steht für zwei was eine initially. Und nun trifft es sich, dass der Mensch, der diesen Editor für die Lisp-Maschine geschrieben hat, der Mensch, der diesen zwei geschrieben hat, diesen Editor für die kommerzielle Lisp-Maschine, der war dann später bei Harlequin und hat bei Harlequin auch einen Editor in Dylan geschrieben, der dann jetzt Deuce heißt. Und es gibt also in diesem Source-Code, der Source-Code ist natürlich immer repository, wie ungefähr eine Million andere Zeilen Dylan, also ist tatsächlich so der Umfang des derzeitigen Compendiums an Dylan-Code. Er hat in einem Rhythmus geschrieben, endlich, endlich, endlich konnte er mal den Editor so implementieren, wie man das will. Es gibt ja verschiedene Modelle, Editorn zu implementieren, wie man seine Struktur verwaltet, wie man das Einfügen von Charaktern handelt. Und Deuce hat also polymorphe-Buffer-Pointer. Das heißt, dass man sich Stellen in seinem Text merken kann, die dann auch mitwandern, wenn man Text einfügt. Also Buffer-Pointer sind ein sehr fundamentales Konzept bei Editoren. Und die sind halt Objekte. Und man kann da Polymorphie verwenden, um irgendwie ganz einfach so tolle Sachen zu implementieren, wie verschiedene Fonds und Syntax-Hilatting und Collapsing und Expanding. Und überhaupt kann man das jetzt alles sehr, sehr viel schicker machen.
Okay, das ist schön. Jetzt haben wir diese EMAX-Geschichte auch nochmal abgehandelt. Das habe ich aber schon wieder ganz vergessen, wobei ich dich gerade unterbrochen habe.
Wir waren bestimmt bei Sprachfeatures.
Wir waren definitiv bei Sprachfeatures. Ich erinnere mich jetzt nicht mehr, an welche wir waren. Aber wir können ja nochmal zu dem nächsten voranschreiten, denn es gibt ja noch die Möglichkeit, verschiedene Klassen zu neuen Klassen neu zusammenzugruppieren, ohne dass man jetzt das Vererbungsschema anwendet.
Ja, da sind wir nicht bei Klassen, sondern da sind wir bei Typen. Typen und Klassen unterscheiden sich. Zwar sind Klassen auch Typen, aber es gibt auch noch Typen, die jenseits von Klassen sind. Zum Beispiel gibt es den Singleton-Typ. Das hat nichts mit dem Singleton-Pattern zu tun, oder nur sie entfernt. Das ist aber der Typ, der durch genau eine Instanz eines Objektes erfüllt wird. Ein simples Beispiel. Integer ist ein Typ, das sind halt alle Zahlen. Und die Zahl 1 ist einmal die Instanz eines Integers, aber man kann auch sagen, der Typ von allen Objekten, die die Zahl 1 sind, was halt genau nur die Zahl 1 ist und sonst nichts anderes. Dann gibt es Union-Types. Das sind halt einfach Vereinigungsoperationen auf Typen. Also Union von foo und bar ist entweder foo oder bar. Und beides zusammen, Singleton-Types und Union-Types, kann man sehr schön verwenden, um ein Problem zu lösen, das einen immer ärgert als Programmierer. Und zwar das Problem der reservierten Werte. Sagen wir mal, man hat eine Funktion, die einen Integer zurückgibt. Das möchte man aber manchmal sagen, ich hab gar kein Ergebnis berechnet, sondern ich hab was anderes. Dann macht man dann so Sachen wie minus 1 zurückgeben. Und es ist dann klar, dass minus 1 eine besondere Bedeutung hat. Ist natürlich problematisch, weil vielleicht rechnet man ja doch mal minus 1 aus und will das zurückgeben. Und was man da in Dylan machen kann, ist, dass man halt einen Union-Typ baut von Integer und dem Singleton false. Dafür gibt es dann auch eine Abkürze. Man kann also sagen false or integer. Und das ist dann ein Typ, der genau von allen Integern und dem Boolean false erfüllt wird. Ich weiß also, die Funktion gibt einen Integer zurück oder false.
Das heißt, man weiß auch, dass es definitiv nichts anderes gibt. Das heißt, man kann einfach seine Zahlen zurückgeben in der Funktion, aber wenn irgendwas passiert ist, was einen Fehler ausdrückt oder eine Unmöglichkeit der Anfragebedienung, je nachdem, welche Parameter dann übergeben werden, dann gibt man einfach false auf. Und das ist korrekt, weil man hat halt einen Typ definiert, der entweder integer ist oder false. Und genau das nutzt man in dem Moment. Man kann es auch klar unterscheiden.
Also wer jemals Java programmiert hat, der kennt das berüchtigte Null-Pointer-Problem. Also in Java ist es so, dass jeder Pointer auch Null sein kann. Das heißt, jeder Typ, den man hinschreiben kann, hat die potenzielle Eigenschaft, dass wenn man das auf das Objekt zugreift, das mit einer Null-Pointer-Exception schiefgeht. Genau, also da ist sozusagen dieses Out of Band, ich habe hier kein Objekt in der Hand, implizit überall mit drin. Das heißt, man kann nicht unterscheiden bei der Definition einer Funktion, ob die immer einen gültigen Wert zurückgibt, wenn man sich darauf verlassen kann. Oder ob es auch mal Null-Pointer oder False, oder ein Kann-Ich-Nicht-Berechnen sein kann. Das kann man nicht sehen. In Dylan kann man das ausdrücken. Wenn man eine Funktion hat, die Integer zurückliefert und nicht False oder Integer, dann kann man da auch Plus drauf aufrufen, ohne dass einem das um die Ohren fliegen wird. Man weiß, dieser Fehler kann nicht passieren.
Eine andere schöne Sache von Dylan, die ich sehr nett fand, ist die Art und Weise, mit Exceptions umzugehen. Das ist sogar noch etwas softer definiert. Der Überbegriff lautet hier Conditions. Damit kann man bestimmte Zustände des Programms, die es in irgendwelchen Bedingungen erreicht, ganz elegant ausdrücken.
Ja, also Exceptions hat man auch schon mal gesehen. Man schreibt in C++ oder Java 3 hin. Wenn es schief geht, gibt es da ein Accept-Ding. In Accept kann man sich die Exception angucken, die da gekommen ist und dann feststellen, dass alles doof war.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein heeres Ziel. Man will ein bisschen fehlertolerant sein, man will für den Fall vorbereitet sein, dass irgendwas schief geht.
Ja, ist erstmal nicht schlecht. Allerdings ist es so, dass da eigentlich zwei Sachen miteinander vermischt werden. Und zwar einmal die Tatsache, man hat einen Ausnahmezustand. Und der Ort, an dem man weiß, wie man mit dem Ausnahmezustand umgeht, ist nicht derselbe wie der, wo der Fehler auftritt. Und man möchte es handeln. Und das andere, was damit reinkommt, ist, dass quasi die Berechnung, die ja durch irgendwie viele verschachtelte Funktionsaufrufe durchgeht, abgebrochen wird und ein sogenanntes Stack-Anweinding gemacht wird und der zurückspringt an die Stelle, wo er mal Trail und Accept gesagt hat, um die Operation zu beenden, ein sogenannter Non-Local-Exit. Und bei Dylan werden diese beiden Sachen getrennt. Das heißt, es ist erstmal so, es gibt sogenannte Conditions, zu denen gibt es Warnings und Errors und beliebige andere Conditions, die man sich dahin programmieren kann, für die man einen Händler registrieren kann. Man kann also sagen, wenn eine Condition auftaucht, sag mir Bescheid. Der große Unterschied ist der, dass der Händler, der da aufgerufen wird, ist eine Funktion, Funktionen sind First Class Objects, kann ich irgendwo herholen die Funktion, die wird dann erstmal von da aus, wo der Fehler passiert ist, aufgerufen. Und ich habe die Möglichkeit an der Stelle dann den Fehler zu beheben und das Programm weiterlaufen zu lassen.
Also, ein klassisches Beispiel ist, ich schreibe eine Datei und füge neue Daten hinten mit an und dann ist irgendwie die Platte voll. So, dann wäre die Condition in dem Fall diskfull. Und dann würde automatisch Kot aufgerufen werden, der sich das sozusagen anschaut und dann irgendwie guckt, ja prima, das ist voll, dann kann ich ja mal hier Objekte aus dem Cache rauswerfen, die da gerade auf der Festplatte eine ganze Menge Platz belegen, die aber an dieser Stelle nicht wichtig sind, weil es so notwendig halt wieder neu geholt ist, ja nur ein Cache. Und dann kann er an der gleichen Stelle wieder weitermachen.
Genau, das ist das Besondere dabei, dass der Stack erstmal nicht abgeräumt wird, sondern dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, in so einem Händler für eine Condition das Problem zu beseitigen, auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise, und es dann weiterlaufen zu lassen.
Und das ohne irgendeinen Code für diesen Fall hinschreiben zu müssen, also zumindest nicht an der Stelle, wo das Problem auftritt.
Nicht da, wo das Problem auftritt, sondern an der Stelle, wo man weiß, wie man mit dem Problem umgeht.
Das heißt, bei diesem Diskful-Beispiel schreibe ich sozusagen an einer einzigen Stelle mal für den Fall, dass die Platte voll ist, baue ich jetzt hier sozusagen eine Maßnahme ein, wie zum Beispiel das mit dem Cache, und das kann ich dann überall benutzen?
Genau so ist das. Also überall da, wo die passende Exception erzeugt wird. Der Vorteil ist, dass man das entkoppeln kann. Je nachdem, was für eine Art Anwendung man schreibt, kann man völlig unterschiedlich mit Fehlerzuständen umgehen. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Web-Server schreibe, dann ist so ein Diskful-Condition etwas, was der Web-Server bitte möglichst selber beheben sollte, so er dazu in der Lage ist, und vielleicht muss er auch einfach den Admin rufen. Aber bei einer GUI-Anwendung kann man dann ein Fenster aufmachen und den User fragen, na willst du vielleicht woanders hin speichern, oder wie wär's denn, du probierst es nochmal mit aufzuräumen, sagst du, lass mich weiterlaufen. Also die Art und Weise, wie man mit einem Fehler umgeht, die unterscheidet sich ja stark von der Anwendung, aber der eigentliche Kopiervorgang ist jedes Mal derselbe. Und natürlich gibt es auch das mit dem Stack-Anweinding, weil manchmal hat man ja Situationen, wo man halt nicht mehr weitermachen kann, wo man eine Berechnung abbrechen muss, weil es keine mögliche Heilung gibt für das Problem. Und da kommen die Non-Local Exits ins Spiel, die man mit einem Statement hinschreibt, das oberflächlich erstmal ähnlich aussieht. Man sagt nämlich Blog. Und dann gibt es in dem Blog einen Condition-Händler, den man da hinschreiben kann, beziehungsweise sagt man Blog-Klammer auf, Return-Klammer zu. Man definiert sich damit eine Variable namens Return. In der steckt eine Funktion drin. Wenn man die Funktion aufruft, kann man sich das vorstellen, als springt er dann an das Blogende. Mit dem großen Unterschied, dass es nicht wirklich wie ein Go-To funktioniert, weil nämlich das Return eine Funktion ist, die ich auch wieder in eine Variable tun kann oder woanders hin tun kann. Und mir zum Beispiel auch merken kann und zum Beispiel auch ein Blog-Statement machen kann. Dann ein Condition-Händler definieren, der wieder auf dieses Return zugreift. Und dann, wenn er irgendwo mal die Entscheidung getroffen hat, ich muss jetzt abbrechen, wieder dieses Return aufruft. Und das kann in einer völlig anderen Funktion sein, wenn ich mir das Return zwischendrin gemerkt habe.
Ja, jetzt haben wir eine ganze Menge von den, also ich denke von den Features genannt, wo Dylan auch wirklich erhebliche Unterschiede aufweist. Natürlich gehen so diese ganzen anderen Sachen, die man so erwartet, natürlich auch vorhanden. Fehlt dir eigentlich irgendetwas? Gibt es irgendetwas, was Dylan nicht hat?
Es gibt keine prozeduralen Makros und es gibt kein Meta-Object-Protokoll.
Klingt nicht unbedingt jetzt wie Features, nach denen man als erstes fragt?
Das sind ja so, ich würde sagen schon, die abgefahrensten, aber auch sehr mächtige Features, die CRE-LISP noch hat. Zu den Makros muss man vielleicht noch was sagen. Also Dylan hat durchaus Makros, die sich auch von den Makros, wie man sie so aus C++ kennt, unterscheiden. Weil die Makros nicht auf Text-Substitutionsebene arbeiten, sondern auf Substitutionsebene auf dem Parstree. Das heißt, auf dem Syntax-Baum der Sprache, der Grammatik.
Das heißt, ich kann mit den Makros quasi den Sprachumfang erweitern. Ich kann neue Konstrukte einführen, die ich genauso benutze wie die bestehenden Konstrukte, die auf dem gleichen Level sind. Das ist nicht irgendwie so ein Text auspacken, wie jetzt bei C mit Define, sondern ich schaffe mir sozusagen meinen eigenen Dialekt.
Genau, also wenn es so etwas wie V nicht gäbe, könnte man es sich mit Hilfe der Makros implementieren.
Aber ich kann mir auch so mein eigenes vorbauen, was einfach bestimmte Bedingungen hat.
Genau, und sein eigenes If. Und wenn einem irgendwie das mit dem Case-Setment nicht gefällt, macht man sich das halt anders, dass es auch als Makro implementiert. Man verwendet das gerne für sogenannte Domain-Specific Languages. Beispiel, man definiert sich einen Parser, dann hat man ja eine Grammatik, man hat Produktion in der Grammatik. Dann kann man sich einen Makro machen, das dann Define Parser Grammar heißt, und wo man dann hinschreibt Production und die erste Produktion und Production, die nächste Produktion. Das heißt, man kann sich eine schickere Syntax für seine Definition machen. Das ist auch etwas, was halt aus der LISP-Welt bekannt ist. Und auch das Schlagwort Domain-Specific Language ist da ein sehr, sehr wichtiges. Und was diese prozeduralen Makros machen, ist etwas, was ich vielleicht ganz am Anfang schon mal erwähnt habe. Nämlich, dass tatsächlich Code ausgeführt wird, der auf Code arbeitet. Das also mein Makro ist nicht bloß eine Substitution auf dem Pastry sind, sondern dass tatsächlich Code ausgeführt wird, der Entscheidungen treffen kann, wie eine Substitution durchgeführt wird. Das klingt sehr abgefahren, das ist auch sehr abgefahren. Nichtsdestotrotz ist es etwas, was sehr mächtig ist und was man gerne haben möchte, um sich seine Domainspecific Language für komplexere Anwendungsfälle zu bauen. Der von Harlekin geerbte Compiler, der, wir müssen den Namen nochmal sagen, Open Dillon heißt mittlerweile, seitdem er Open Source ist, der verwendet tatsächlich prozedurale Makros intern, um sich Sachen zu definieren. Sie machen da solche Sachen wie, sich in dem Compiler Objekte zu definieren, die dann in der Runtime des zu kompilenden Programms existieren, die aber gleichzeitig einen Handel dafür bieten, mit dem der Compiler zur Runtime des Compilers das Objekt wieder anfassen kann. Das hat jetzt bestimmt nicht jeder nachvollziehen können, was ich sagen möchte.
Wir treten jetzt in den metaphysischen Bereich ein.
Das ist ganz klar der Bereich der Metaprogrammierung, wo man mit Programmen zu tun hat, die Programme bearbeiten. Das ist vielleicht etwas, was man nicht vermitteln kann, wenn man das noch nie getan hat, welche Macht und welche Ausdrucksmöglichkeit dahinter steckt. Wenn man sein ganzes Leben lang bloß Integer von links nach rechts und Pointer von plus nach minus geschoben hat, dann hat man das nicht. Dann kann man sich vielleicht auch gar nicht vorstellen, was das heißt, welche Probleme da in lösbare Reichweite kommen, die vorher nicht lösbar gewesen wären. Aber das ist schon so die metalinguistische Abstraktion, die Krönung des Programmierens. Wenn man beim Programmieren so weit ist, dass man sich die Programmiersprache für das zu lösende Problem anpasst, weil es anders nicht lösbar ist.
Ihr habt da gerade was gehackt unter Zuhilfenahmen von Markus, was eigentlich eine ganz simple Anwendung ist. Das ist ein Packet-Sniffer und ein Protokoll-Auseinanderpacker. Kannst du mal kurz erklären, wie du das gemacht hast, wie die Anwendung war?
Da haben wir auch die Makros verwendet, um Protokoll-Pakete zu beschreiben, also auf Netzwerkebene. So ein IP-Paket besteht aus einem Versionsfeld, einer Target, einer Source, einem IP-Adress, noch so diesem Feld hier und jenem Feld da. Es ist erstaunlich, dass existierende Software, die sich mit Paketen auseinandersetzt, beim Auseinandernehmen häufig auf die Schnauze fällt. In Etheriel, was eine der beliebtesten Anwendungen für Netzwerke-Analyse ist, waren in den letzten 12 Monaten insgesamt so etwas wie 100 exploitbare Bugs drin, also Bugs, die dazu geführt haben, dass man den Rechner von demjenigen, der es laufen hat, lassen, übernehmen kann, da einbrechen kann. Und das ist einfach ein Zustand, der nicht tragbar ist. Auch wenn man sich die Implementierung anguckt, ist es da so, dass man nicht einmal an einer Stelle sagt, pass mal auf, es gibt IP-Pakete, und da ist eine Source-Address drin, das ist eine IP-Adresse, und eine IP-Adresse sind übrigens vier Bytes, sondern ich hab nachgezählt, es steht an sage und schreibe 40 verschiedenen Stellen, dass es da so eine Source-Address in einem IP-Paket gibt, und an welcher Stelle die anfängt, und wo sie aufhört, und wie das mit dem Byte-Offset ist, und dass es übrigens eine Source-Adress ist, und dass es sich da bei meiner IP-Adresse handelt.
Also relativ wenig Reviews sozusagen.
Relativ wenig Reviews, man muss alles mehrfach sagen, und das ist eigentlich etwas, was ich also zutiefst ablehne. Einerseits bin ich zu faul, es 40 mal hinzuschreiben, aber viel schlimmer, wenn man es 40 mal hinschreibt, hat man 40 mal die Gelegenheit, einen Fehler dabei zu machen, nicht nur einmal. Und auch die Gelegenheit, den Fehler so zu machen, dass man ihn nicht unmittelbar sofort merkt. Ziel war, unsere Entwicklung etwas zu haben, was uns einerseits erlaubt, es möglichst kompakt hinzuschreiben, wie so ein Paket aussieht, was aber auf der anderen Seite auch dazu führt, dass es nicht crasht, wenn man halt komische Dinge in die Pakete reinschreibt, dass die Pase also so gebaut sind, dass sie möglichst nicht kaputt gehen und wenn sie kaputt gehen, in einer Art und Weise kaputt gehen, die nicht zu einer Exportbarkeit des Programms führt.
Das ist jetzt ein interessanter Punkt. Du hast ja auf dem letzten Kongress auch einen Vortrag über Dülen gehalten unter dem Aspekt, dass es sicheres Programmieren fördert. Also da ging es jetzt gar nicht mal so sehr darum, dass man jetzt die bessere Ausdruckskraft hat und dass man dieses und jedes Meter Problem machen kann, sondern du vertrittst ja an der Stelle die Auffassung und die These, dass man eben dadurch, dass man dynamische Programmiersprachen benutzt, die eben so einen hohen Grad an Abstraktionsfähigkeit haben, dass dadurch einfach Fehler vermieden werden, die Sicherheitslöchern zuträglich sind.
Das hat noch nicht unbedingt was mit den dynamischen Features zu tun, sondern das ist mehr eine Eigenschaft der strikten Typisierung. Das heißt, dass die Typen vom Compiler immer eingehalten werden, wenn es für den Programmierer keinen Weg drum herum gibt. Also in erster Linie ist das eigentlich die Erkenntnis, dass C mal abgeschafft gehört. Und ein C-geschriebenes Software gehört auch abgeschafft. Und es ist einfach sowas von klar und offensichtlich, dass die Frage nicht ist, ob wir C abschaffen müssen, sondern nur, was wir nehmen, um es zu ersetzen und wann es endlich soweit ist. Und aufbauend darauf sage ich halt, dass Dylan da eine geeignete Sprache ist. Und sage zusätzlich, dass Dylan unter den Sprachen, die nicht C sind, eine ist, die auch sehr, sehr geeignet ist, weil sie hohe Absraktionsmöglichkeiten hat. Also es ist eigentlich eine zweistufige Akumulation. Die erste Stufe ist, wir müssen C wegwerfen, weil es scheiße ist. Es ist erwiesenermaßen so, dass es nicht möglich ist, komplexe Systeme in C zu schreiben, ohne dass sie einen unter den Fingern wegbröseln und Scriptkiddies einem im Rechner übernehmen und man anfängt, Spam zu versenden, weil irgendwelche Viren das infiziert haben. Und der zweite Schritt ist zu sagen, dass unter den Sprachen, die uns zur Verfügung stehen, halt mächtige und weniger mächtige sind und dass Dylan eine der mächtigeren Sprachen ist. Die ist halt auch erlaubt, wenn man alles neu schreiben muss, will man ja nicht so viel arbeiten, dann kann man gleich eine Sprache nehmen, der das nicht so viel Arbeit ist, und man das so gut machen kann.
Jetzt bist du ja in dem Gwirion-Projekt, oder nennt es dich jetzt Open Dylan Projekt, habt du da bei dem Namen schon irgendwie einen Weg gefunden?
Oh, das ist schwierig. Momentan steht Dylan Hackers drunter, was natürlich ein Problem ist, wenn man sich Dylan Hackers nennt. Du und ich wissen, wo der Begriff Hacker herkommt, aber wenn man zu Leuten läuft, die einem Geld dafür geben sollen, dass man das macht, dann ist es besser, wenn man Foundation oder was auch immer heißt.
Und irgendwas mit Open am besten. Also der Begriff Open Dylan ist jetzt eigentlich für diesen Compiler gewählt worden, der bei Harlequin rausgefallen ist, wie auch immer. Also auch unter opendyln.org kann man eure Webseite erreichen, aber viel wichtiger ist jetzt, was denn der Ist-Zustand des Projektes ist. Also meine Wahrnehmung ist, es gibt da irgendwie über den Planeten verteilt 10 Leute ungefähr, die da mehr oder weniger tief den Kopf drin haben, diesen Projekt und versuchen in irgendeiner Form diese riesen Mengen an Code nutzbar zu machen.
Ja, das ist nicht so ganz falsch, wobei die Anzahl der Leute größer wird. Also noch vor zwei Jahren waren es eher vier, die da aktiv dran gearbeitet haben. Es sind mehr geworden. Einerseits dadurch, dass das Open Dillon Open Source geworden ist, das hat Leute angezogen. Andererseits natürlich durch den Erfolg beim ICFP-Contest, der auch nochmal Leute gezogen hat. Und es ist schon so, dass wir von den Beta-Releases von Open Dillon mehrere hundert Downloads haben. Also es gibt mehr als nur zwei oder drei User. Es gibt eine Community von einem Dutzend Leuten, die tatsächlich aktiv was machen, die also regelmäßig im Channel sind, die Code bearbeiten, die einchecken. Aber auch User. Wir arbeiten gerade dran, das Open Dillon quasi releasefertig zu machen. Wir haben da eine Beta bekommen, die so ein bisschen mittendrin war, die halt noch gewisse Mankos hat. Also funktioniert Debugging nur, wenn man unter Windows arbeiteten Visual C++ 6.0 installiert hat, was also eine relativ einschreckende Bedingung ist und etwas, was dringend gefixt gehört. Wir machen Portierungen. Wir haben jetzt einen Linux-Port schon vor einiger Zeit gemacht für die Beta 1. Wir sind jetzt gerade dabei, die Beta 2 rauszubringen. Die wird auch ein FreeBSD-Port enthalten. Erstmal nur den Command-Line-Compiler, die Entwicklungsumgebung, der Debugger, hängen noch an Sachen, die nicht fertig sind. Also Debugger-Interfacing, die GUI-Library, usw.
Aber es ist zumindest eine ganze Menge Zeug da und vieles bedarf einfach noch mal eines weiteren Augenpares. Wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, jemand hat uns jetzt hier zugehört und die Leute, die jetzt noch nicht abgeschaltet haben, die gehören wahrscheinlich sowieso zu den härtesten und den Leuten, die sowieso von nichts genug bekommen können. Aber wenn man jetzt sozusagen Interesse daran hat, mit Dylan zu entwickeln, was gibt es also konkret? Also es gibt einen Compiler, der läuft unter Windows. Es gibt denselben Compiler, der läuft im Prinzip auch schon ein wenig unter Linux, hat aber nicht alle Features von der Windows-Version. Sehe ich das richtig?
Der Compiler selber läuft, der läuft halt als Batch-Compiler. Also unter Windows gibt es halt eine Entwicklungsumgebung mit Editor und Code-Browser und Debugger und Profiler und so dem ganzen Full-Defense, der dazugehört.
Also schon richtig nifty Zeug eigentlich.
Ja, so wie man das haben will. Unter Linux gibt es einen Batch-Compiler, das heißt, man wirft eine Library rein, man bekommt ein Executable bzw. eine Shared Library unten raus. Der Debugger ist halt noch nicht fertig. Man kann mit GDB so ein bisschen debuggen. Ist allerdings nicht besonders komfortabel, weil man nicht auf Dylensource-Ebene debuggen kann, weil man sich die Objekte halt nicht per Mausklick angucken kann.
Aber man kann sich das runterladen und man ist in der Lage, damit Dylen-Programme zu übersetzen.
Genau.
Und was gibt es so an laufenden Programmen, die man vielleicht noch nutzen könnte, die in Dylen geschrieben sind?
Es gibt echt einen unglaublichen Haufen Zeugs in den verschiedensten Zuständen. Jetzt so richtig Applikationen, die fertig sind. Nicht so viele. Also es gibt Koala. Koala ist ein in Dylen geschriebener Webserver, der aber auch als Library verwendet werden kann. Darauf gibt es eine Wiki-Implementierung, die rudimentär ist. Es gibt ein Tool zum Management von IP-Netzwerken, also auf dem letzten Chaos-Communication-Congress haben wir dieses Tool namens Buddha verwendet, um damit das Management der VLANs zu machen und der IP-Adressen, die auf dem VLAN vergeben werden, inklusive Generierung der DHCP.
Also für das Kongressnetzwerk.
Genau. Ja, und dann gibt es halt, jetzt neu dazugekommen, ist eine Library, die XMPP implementiert, also um Java sprechen zu können. Natürlich gibt es dann auch den XML-Parse, auf den es aufbaut. Es gibt eine Cobra-Implementierung. Was fällt mir spontan noch ein an Libraries? Alles mögliche Grafikbibliotheken. Es gibt drin den Dylan User Interface Manager, also eine abstrakte Library für User Interfaces, die halt leider derzeit nur eine konkrete Implementierung, nämlich Win32, hat. Es gibt aber drei oder vier zu 90% fertige GTK-Bindings. Also eigentlich ist es bloß eine Sache, wenn irgendjemand mal zwei oder drei Monate da rein investiert, haben wir auch einen Port der IDE auf diverse Unixe.
Und damit eine wirklich moderne, vollständige Entwicklung, eine moderne, vollständige Entwicklungsumgebung für Linux, die frei ist und die wirklich eine extrem moderne Programmiersprache implementiert. Das wäre schon ein heeres Ziel. Was, wenn jetzt jemand Lust hat und so hört irgendwie und er meint, er könnte da vielleicht die notwendige Zeit und Energie aufbringen, um sich soweit in die Sprache reinzufuchsen, dass er in der Lage wäre, bestimmte rumliegende Systeme auch zu Ende zu schreiben. Wo würde man sich da als erstes drauf stürzen wollen? Wo ist sozusagen am dringendsten der Bedarf?
Das hängt immer vom Skill-Level ab. Es gibt viel Dokumentationsbedarf. Vieles einfach mal rumlaufen, gucken, was ein Code da ist, ausprobieren, ob er es kompiliert und mal einen kurzen Text drüber schreiben, ich hab das ausprobiert, das ist so und so weit, die und die Funktionalität ist da, das ist etwas, was getan werden muss. Dann komplexere Projekte wäre, besagtes DWIM-Backend zu schreiben. Das ist also auch ein mittelgroßes Projekt, was noch nicht allzu viele Spezialkenntnisse voraussetzt im Gegensatz zu anderen Compiler-Arbeiten, die getan werden müssen, was aber schon ein größeres Projekt ist. Auch der Webserver muss mal aufgeräumt werden, also sowas wie den HTTP 1.1-Standard zu nehmen und nochmal durch den Code durchzulaufen und gucken, dass alles standardscompliant ist, wäre etwas, was getan werden muss. Was relativ dringend ist, ist Arbeit an dem Debugging-Interface. Also unter Windows wird da die Debug-Help-DLL verwendet, um auf Symbole zuzugreifen. Und da hat sich mal die API geändert. Früher war es halt so, dass man teilweise noch die Files selber parsen musste, um an gewisse Informationen zu kommen. Und diese Informationen stehen jetzt aber nicht mehr drin. Und man muss es aus der anderen DLL holen, damit es halt auch ohne, dass man irgendwie einen sieben Jahre alten Commerz-Compiler von Microsoft noch umliegen haben muss, sondern das mit downloadbaren Tools vielleicht mit dem Gnulink auch geht. Generell die Portierung des gesamten Debuggings auf Linux und FreeBSD. Das heißt, man muss halt 11 Files parsen, die Dwarf-Implementierung verstehen können, P-Trace verwenden, damit man ordentlich Debuggen, Profilen und Interacten kann unter Unix. Ja, wir haben da so ein halbfertiges Wiki, wo mal ein ordentlicher Pasa geschrieben werden müsste, der mal in Betrieb gesetzt werden musste. Also der Baustellen gibt es viele. Und wer Interesse hat, uns mitzuhelfen, ist einmal die Anlaufstelle natürlich die Webseite www.opendylan.org. Und das Hauptkommunikationsmittel der Entwickler ist eigentlich IRC. Das heißt, bei www.irc.freenode.net Channel Dylan sind eigentlich 24-7 Entwickler zu finden, die auch bei beliebigen Dylan-Problemen gerne bereit sind, Support zu leisten.
Ja, jetzt haben wir hier den längsten Chaosradio Express aller Zeiten produziert.
Ich hab Havl geschlagen.
Ja, sieht so aus. Aber ich glaube, Havl wird zurückschlagen, weil er hat schon angekündigt, dass er durchaus mal auch mit mir den Walkthrough durch C++ machen soll, wo er ja ein großer Verfechter ist, wie du weißt. Das wird sicherlich ganz spannend zu sein, aber wir wollten auf jeden Fall auch mal auf Dylan hinweisen, weil Dylan ist wirklich eine tolle Geschichte und da steckt so viel Intelligenz drin von wirklich klugen Leuten, die sehr lange über das Problem nachgedacht haben, mit den Prognomiersprachen und wenn es auch keine Dauerbeschäftigung für euch wird, auf jeden Fall eine Bewusstseinserweiterung, kann es auf jeden Fall hervorrufen. opendylan.org ist der Ort, wo ihr nachschauen könnt und im ERC-Kanal findet ihr die Leute, die sicherlich jedes Hilfe angeboten, auch jede Nachfrage, wenn mal was nicht verstanden wird, beantworten können. Ja, und mir bleibt nur euch hier mit diesem Hardcore-Programmierer-Podcast euch zurückzulassen, euch noch viel Spaß zu wünschen. Andreas und ich, wir sagen Tschüss.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Und wir hören uns beim nächsten Chaosradio Express, der nicht so kompliziert wird wie dieser, oder vielleicht auch doch, wir wissen es nicht. Thema habe ich eh noch nicht parat. Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Tag.